du monde de rugby oblige Daniel Herero
est notre invité dans un monde un regard
les entretiens de Public Sénat un monde
un regard avec Daniel Herero vendredi à
17h30 sur Public
[Musique]
Sénat bonjour bonjour à tous bienvenue
sur Public Sénat édition spéciale à
l'occasion de l'élection du président du
Sénat après le renouvellement de la
chambre haute le 24 septembre dernier
place donc au 3e tour et il y a quatre
candidats au plateau Cécile cuquierman
pour le groupe communiste Patrick canner
pour le groupe socialiste Guillaume
Gontard est le candidat des écologistes
et Gérard Larché celui de la majorité de
la droite et du centre Gérard Larcher
candidat à sa succession pour un 5e M
mandat de président et qui devrait donc
l'emporter on va vous faire vivre cet
événement tout l'après-midi sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat avec notre duo
de journalistes avec Quentin Calmet dans
la salle des conférences à quelques
mètres de l'hémicycle Quentin vous allez
avoir cette après-midi de nombreux
invités à votre micro voilà on va faire
aussi un point sur l'ambiance ici en
salle des conférences c'est un peu la
rentrée des classe la rentrée
parlementaire qui se joue aussi
aujourd'hui le 2 octobre avec l'arrivée
aussi de nouveau sénateur et le retour
de tous les parlementaires ici à la
Chambre haute et on fera le point comme
cela sur les sujets chauds de cette
rentrée avec de nombreux invités à mon
micro th merci merci beaucoup Quentin et
à tout à l'heure également avec nous
Mathias Arz dans la tribune de presse de
l'émicycle pour nous faire vivre de
l'intérieur cette élection qui marque
aussi le début de la session
parlementaire avec ce Sénat renouvelé
alors Mathias comment ça va se passer
alors en ouverture de cette session
parlementaire Tam c'est le doyen de
l'hémicycle le sénateur centriste
Jean-Marie vanlerenberg 84 ans récemment
réélu dans son département du Pas
decalis qui prendra la parole en tant
que président du bureau d'âge un bureau
d'âge composé du Doyen donc mais
également de six secrétaires les six
sénateurs les plus jeunes on peut citer
Mathilde Olivier Rémy Cardon Alexandre
wiouiszy Sébastien fagnan Joshua
auchochard et Audry bellim dont le rôle
aujourd'hui sera de s'assurer de la
bonne tenue du scrutin une ouverture de
session avec un discours solennel sur le
rôle de l'INS institution du du Sénat
notamment une fois le discours terminé
place au tirage au sort de l'ordre
d'appel le principe est simple on tire
une lettre de l'alphabet au sort et les
sénateurs dont le nom de famille
commence par cette lettre et bien seront
les premiers à voter un vote à bulletin
secret qui devrait se tenir entre 15h et
16h Tam merci merci beaucoup à tous les
deux on vous retrouve tout au long de
l'après-midi pour nous faire vivre ce
scrutin bien particulier et qui n'a lieu
qu'une fois tous les 3 ans au Sénat
trois invités sur ce plateau pour
discuter des enjeux de l'élection mais
aussi pour se projeter sur le début de
la session parlementaire quelles vont
être les relations du Sénat et du
gouvernement notamment quels sont les
grands textes qui nous attendent avec
nous sur ce plateau j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir Pascal Perino bonjour
bonjour vous êtes politologue professeur
à Science Po et vous êtes notamment
l'auteur de ce livre le vote clivé les
élections présidentielle et législative
d'avril et juin 2022 au Pug les Presses
Universitaires de Grenoble également
avec nous jean-garic bonjour bonjour
vous êtes historien président du Comité
d'histoire parlementaire et politique
vous êtes notamment l'auteur de Élysée
contre Matignon de 1958 à nos jours aux
éditions Talandier et je cite également
votre livre à venir d'ici 2 jours je
crois jours heureux chez Paillot et
enfin sur ce plateau Jean-Baptiste foret
bonjour bonjour vous êtes rédacteur en
chef délégué de la Gazette des communes
et vous êtes l'auteur de ce livre au
cœur du Grand déclassement la fierté
perdue de Peugeot socho aux éditions du
SER Pascal Perino quatre candidats pour
un plateau mais pas beaucoup de suspense
on peut le dire Gérard Larcher devrait
retrouver la présidence du Sénat pour
une 5è fois tout à fait euh si vous
voulez la l'élection de la présidence du
Sénat ce sont c'est le reflet direct des
élections qui ont eu lieu dimanche 28
septembre donc là on a vu en effet que
la droite et le centre restaient
majoritaire la droite républicaine a
connu une lég érosion le centre a
extrêmement bien résisté et puis on sait
aussi la capacité de Gérard Larcher à
aller régulièrement au-delà de sa
majorité lorsqu'il s'agit de l'élection
du du président du du Sénat on l'avait
vu il y a 3 ans on l'avait vu il y a 6
ans donc il aura certainement une
majorité qui devrait dépasser les
effectifs Union centriste plus
républicain et ce niveau sera
intéressant parce que cela
montrera la capacité
de Gérard Larcher à être véritablement
quelqu'un de tout à fait central dans
cette institution c'est en effet vous
venez de le dire s'il est réélu la 5è
fois qu'il sera réélu mais c'est pas du
tout un record il faut savoir que dans
le passé Alain poè avait été réélu fois
h
fois gouverné il avait gouverné le Sénat
pendant 24 ans ah oui jean- gar c'est
une marque du Sénat effectivement il y a
eu relativement peu de présidents du
Sénat ils sont réélus vraiment il y a
une Constance en fait qui marque aussi
l'histoire de cette chambre oui tout à
fait la longévité mais cadre bien avec
cet esprit de sagesse de modération que
que veut incarner et qu'a incarné tout
au long de son histoire d'ailleurs le
Sénat qui n' guerre s'appelait le Sénat
conservateur d'ailleurs donc vous avez
eu des des des Longs Prés des longues
présidences du Sénat y compris au début
de la la 5e République Gaston monerville
est quand même resté une dizaines
d'années avec des tensions très fortes
avec le président de la République avec
Charles de Gaulle alors après après il y
a eu évidemment Alain poè qui a été le
grand président du Sénat vous avez René
monouri n'est pas resté très très
longtemps Christian pcelet un peu plus
et là avec Gérard Larché on a
l'impression qu'il se lance à l'assaut
du record de d'Alain poer mais ce sera
quand même difficile à battre non ce qui
est important c'est que le le le
président du Sénat dans la conjoncture
actuelle et et et Pascal est bien placé
pour pour le savoir joue un rôle majeur
sans doute encore plus important que que
que ses prédécesseurs parce que dans
dans l'état actuel des des rapports de
force politiqu de ce qu'est l'Assemblée
nationale on a vu que le le Sénat
aujourd'hui allait jouer un rôle majeur
dans la j'allais dire la le rapport des
forces politique et dans la construction
de des lois dans la fabrication des lois
donc cette élection là elle a une
dimension encore plus exceptionnel me
semble-t-il que que d'habitude
jeanbadiste for on le disait donc
gerardarcher personnage central du Sénat
personnage aussi central aujourd'hui
donc dans dans la vie politique dans un
sens plus large avec les bouleversements
parlementair récent et la nouvelle
Assemblée élue en 2022 oui ben on a vu
par exemple que les textes désormais
passaient toujours en premier lieu au
Sénat ce sera notamment le cas du texte
beaucoup plus tout cas ce sera le texte
ce sera le cas en tout cas du texte sur
l'immigration quelques semaines qui est
très très attendu d'ailleurs c'est une
d'une certaine façon pour Gérard Larcher
parce qu'il incarnait un peu l'ancien
monde il ressemble un peu à une
caricature de de domier de la trè de la
3è République c'est un peu le le gros
matou de la République Gérard larchi on
s'en méfiait pas tellement et puis il
sait donner des coups de griffe quand il
faut il sait aussi accoucher de
compromis d'accord entre les diverses
force force politiques on a vu notamment
son rôle clé au moment des retraites et
puis joue un rôle clé là dans un domaine
qui m'intéresse particulièrement à la
Gazette des communes c'est c'est dans le
domaine des collectivités c'est le
parrain des élus locaux j' larch et
làdis aussi fait l'unanimité chez les
élus locaux ah oui oui c'est une sorte
de Rockstar Gérard Larché quand il va
dans les congrès d'association d'élu il
est applaudi sur tous les bancsf y
compris y compris à gauche alors on va
continuer à parler bien sûr de cette
élection sans doute réélection de Gérard
Larcher cette élection c'est aussi un
moment très codifié un moment très
solennel tout un cérémonial qui met en
scène le bureau d'âge Mathias en a parlé
un petit peu tout à l'heure il y a les
plus jeunes sénateurs et le plus âgé qui
sont-ils audre
vetaz entre les deux 55 ans d'écart il a
84 ans elle en a 29 mais il porte
désormais la même écharpe celle de
sénateur Jean-Marie van lurenberg est
une figure du pas decalis il entame son
4e mandat de sénateur après avoir été
maire d'aras pendant 16 ans proche de
François baayrou avec lequel il a
cofondé le modem il revendique son
indépendance son âge il en a conscience
et compte profiter de ce mandat pour
passer le témoin j'ai l'âge que j'ai je
le sais je suis en forme dieu merci mais
je sais aussi qu'il faut savoir
transmettre dans la vie quand on a des
valeurs c'est pour les transmettre quand
on a des idées c'est pour les faire
vivre anecdote étonnante il siégera et
c'est une première au côté de sa fille
Isabelle Floren élue sén des hautes
scènes Mathilde Olivier de son côté
foule pour la première fois les marches
du Péron du Sénat bretonne d'origine
elle est installé depuis 4 ans en
Autriche et a été élu dans la
circonscription des Français établis
hors de France sous l'étiquette
écologiste des convictions forgé après
un choc en
1999 le naufrage de l'Erica au large du
finisterère quant à son âge elle compte
bien en faire une force c'est important
pour nous en tout cas pour moi ma
génération de se dire aussi qu'on est
représenté dans toutes les institutions
que on a notre place partout avec
Mathilde Olivier c'est donc la
génération climat qui fait son entrée au
Sénat jean-garré garmau sur ces
cérémoniales très codifié je le disais
le bureau d'âge avec les plus jeunes la
séance présidée par le doyen les
sénateurs placés par ordre alphabétique
c'est tout un protocole qu'on va avoir
cet après-midi oui c'est un protocole et
qui a son utilité parce que c'est aussi
d'abord une manière de rappeler une
histoire le poids de de cette histoire
et une manière aussi de souder ceux qui
font partie de cette nouvelle Assemblée
ce ceux qui viennent d'être élus ou ceux
qui étaient déjà de de les souder autour
de ce autour de ce rituel autour du
doyen d'âge de d'amener les jeunes
justement dans cette ritualisation de de
de la du du du Sénat de du dispositif
sénatorial c'est important d'ouvrir une
une session comme ça avec ce type de de
de ritualisation ceux qui pensent que le
les assemblées doivent être des lieux
comme les autres se trompent il faut
conserver précisément cette ritualité
cette solenité pour bien montrer qu'on
est dans des chambres du peuple mais
qu'on est dans des chambres qui incarne
qui représente aussi la République un
sénat donc qu' l'on découvre renouvelé
et aussi rajuni avec cette élection
Pascal perinoin je regardais les âges là
on arrive à une moyenne de 59 ans et 11
mois de moyenne au lieu de 62 ans et 9
mois avant les dernières élections on a
l'impression que le Sénat bouge peu mais
on voit quand même et bien qu'il bouge à
la marche en certaines choses mais bien
sûr le Sénat il est immergé dans la
société française on le disait tout à
l'heure le Sénat ça représente avant
tout les territoires et la diversité des
territoires de la République donc très
souvent quand on l'attaque sur sa non
représentativité c'est qu'on se trompe
de chambres on utilise pour le Sénat des
arguments qu'on utilise visàvis de
l'Assemblée nationale
le Sénat c'est inscrit au cœur de la
Constitution ça représente les
territoires de la République et en
cela le Sénat joue tout son rôle et son
président joue tout son rôle pour
défendre ces territoires dans lequel on
le sait depuis de nombreuses années il y
a un vrai malaise
social tout à fait et puis il est
immergé les les électeurs sénatoriaux
les dizaines de milliers d'électeurs
sénatoriaux qui se prononcent ce sont
j'allais dire des Français vraiment
comme les autres ce sont des délégués de
conseil municipaux ce sont des
conseillers municipaux ce sont des
maires de petites commune ce sont des
Français comme les autres et la tendance
au rajeunissement la tendance à la
féminisation est à l'œuvre dans ce corps
électoral et dans les candidats qui se
présentent à ce corps électoral donc oui
le Sénat bouge ça a participé d'ailleurs
à l'évolution plutôt positive du Sénat
qui pouvait avoir l'image d'une d'une
comment dire d'une une assemblée
excessivement immobile ce qui était
assez faux mais c'était l'image et en
politique on souffre aussi parfois
d'image un peu un peu voilà et puis
d'autre part on parle beaucoup du Sénat
Jean garig le disait on parle écoutez
depuis quelques mois on on parle
essentiellement du Sénat tout le monde
est à la recherche dans ce dispositif
très centralisé qu'est le deuxème
quinquena d'Emmanuel Macron d'un d'un
contrepoid d'un d'un équ libre et bien
l'équilibre et le contre-poids c'est le
Sénat et il joue tout son rôle dans ce
contre-poids en terme de mission
législative en terme de mission de
contrôle le Sénat est très très actif
contre contrepouvoir hein dit mêmeardch
on va commencer à aller voir et bien
Quentin Calmet qui se trouve salle des
conférences pour quelques réactions
politiques et vous êtes pour commencer
avec Roger carucci sénateur les
républicains des hautes scènes qui vient
d'être réélu d'ailleurs le 24 septembre
bonjour Roger carucci bonjour vous étiez
jusqu'à aujourd'hui un premier
vice-président du Sénat va y avoir
maintenant un nouveau bureau du Sénat
qui va être élu dans les prochains jours
un mot sur ce qui va se jouer dans la
séance qui commence à 15h il y a pas
beaucoup de suspense Gérard lchet
devrait êtreélu président du Sénat vous
le croyez
je ne crois pas j'en suis sûr il sera
réélu président du Sénat dès le premier
tour puisque évidemment il a le soutien
du groupe des Républicains du groupe
Union centriste des indépendants bon
voilà donc a priori il peut compter sur
230 voix sur 348 dès le premier tour
donc il sera élu dès le premier tour 5è
mandat à la présidence du Sénat
qu'est-ce qu'il représente selon vous
gché dans le paysage politique actuel il
a réussi à faire en sorte que plus
personne ne dise que le Sénat est une
anomalie démocratique que plus personne
ne dise le Sénat ça ne sert à rien il
faut le dissoudre ou le faire
disparaître et donc il a réussi
conforter s vrai par le fait qu'il n'y a
pas de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
national mais il a réussi dans le débat
avec l'exécutif à apparaître comme le
véritable interlocuteur du gouvernement
et à faire du Sénat la chambre dans
laquelle on travaille sur le fond des
textes dans la mesure du possible en
première lecture de manière à faire de
bon texte de loi qu'on envoie ensuite à
l'Assemblée quelle doit être la position
politique de la majorité de la droite et
du centre vous le disiez un
interlocuteur privilégié pour l'exécutif
certes mais faut-il être davantage
constructif avec cette majorité ou
faut-il être aussi une chambre qui peut
être une chambre d'opposition face à
l'exécutif quel est votre avis vous sur
le sujet mais en vrai les deux à la fois
c'est-à-dire que le Sénat n'a jamais été
d'opposition systématique quel que soit
le texte quelle que soit la mesure
lorsque on a estimé que la mesure allait
dans le bon sens on l'a adopté lorsque
le gouvernement a fait un un projet de
de finance sur la l'affaire des des
gilets jaunes on l'a adopté après on
n'est pas d'accord surtout sur
l'immigration sur la sécurité sur un
certain nombre de sujets nous ne sommes
pas en accord donc nous n'allons pas
dire oui sur des thèmes sur lesquels
nous ne sommes pas en acccord à partir
de là c'est au gouvernement aussi
d'avancer vers nous vous parliez de du
projet de loi immigration on sait c'est
un texte très chaud très important
politiquement qui arrive à l'automne au
Sénat qui va être la première des deux
chambres à l'examiner dans les
prochaines semaines qu'est-ce que vous
dites sur ce texte où en sommes-nous
faut-il que le gouvernement revienne
complètement sur l'article 3 cette
mesure sur les naturalisations ou les
les titres de séjour pour les les
secteurs en tension le point
d'achopement c'est la article 3 depuis
déjà 9 mois donc est-ce qu'on va trouver
un moyen de trouver une solution je n'en
sais rien nous nous nous disons sur
l'article 3 nous ne transigerons pas
c'està-dire pas l'article 3 tout court
il faut le supprimer complètement il
faut le supprimer ou le réécrire
complètement mais en changeant la nature
alors je vois bien que les centristes
disaient si on le retirait du texte pour
en faire une
circulaire moi les choses qui sont pas
clair ça ça me laisse toujours un peu
perplexe non je pense que le
gouvernement sait depuis les origines
que sur cet article il y a pas d'accord
possible donc est-ce qu'il accepte de le
retirer ou de le réécrire complètement
et bien on va attendre les semaines qui
viennne et bien merci merci pour cette
première réaction au micro de Public
Sénat Tam dans une ambiance ici en salle
des conférences voilà avec pas mal de
monde les sénateurs qui arrivent
notamment les nouveaux et tous les
collègues qui sont en train de se
rencontrer juste derrière nous merci
merci beaucoup Quentin effectivement de
l'effervescence qui monte dans cette
salle des conférences à la proche de
cette élection du président du Sénat
Jean-Baptiste foret euh c'est vrai il y
a eu un changement d'image du Sénat sous
la présidence de Gérard l'arché on se
rappelle on parlait beaucoup de Séna
baching au début des années 2010 et puis
l'image a évoluer dans un sens bien plus
positif oui il faut quand même se
souvenir que que Gérard Larcher a
succédé à Christian Poncelet qui était
quand même à bout de souffle hein on
parlait de
brgéisation du du du du petit Luxembourg
René monori le prédécesseur de monsieur
ponelet était lui-même malade lors de de
ses derniers mois de mandat je parle
même pas de d'Alain poè don don don les
dernières les derniers mois voir les
dernières années ont quand même été très
difficiles Gérard Larché c'est un corps
rond mais en même temps c'est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement tonique en fait hein il
faut il faut se méfier de de l'eau qui
dort et il incarne vraiment ce ce Sénat
qui laboure la France dans tous les sens
on a vu que même dans sa propre
circonscription des départemental des
ivelines il a visité toutes les communes
de son département il fait de la
politique il fait de la politique à
l'ancienne c'est un homme qui n'est pas
calé pour le temps des réseaux sociaux
et paradoxalement c'est ce qui lui est
réussi c'estàdire que contrairement par
exemple aux trois grandes je m'arrêterai
là vous inquiétez pas contrairement aux
trois grandes figures aujourd'hui de la
la politique française àoir à savoir
Emmanuel Macron Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
Marine Le Pen lui il s'est taillé un
fief il fait de la politique comme
pouvait le faire un Jacques Chirac ou ou
un François mitan je dis pas qu'il aura
le même destin alors Jean garig si on en
venait un petit peu au rôle aussi du
président du Sénat quel quel doit être
son rôle il a une responsabilité interne
dans l'institution il a un rôle on a
commencé à en parler au niveau de de la
République un rôle aussi politique
comment est-ce que vous le définiriez
non mais c'est un personnage très
important dans non seulement dans
l'ordre protocolaire de de la République
n'oublion pas que c'est celui qui a
priori peut remplacer un président
pendant inér
politique ou autre donc c'est c'est un
personnage très très important mais ce
qui est très intéressant avec Gérard
Larché particulièrement dans dans ce
rôle c'est d'abord ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale cette forme de
blocage qui existe à l'Assemblée
nationale du fait d'opposition qui sont
des opposition de de destruction ou des
oppositions de d'abstention du côté du
rassemblement national vous avez avec le
le le le Sénat une capacité d'opposition
constructive ça a été dit par par Roger
kucci et et c'est la et c'est la réalité
d'une une opposition qui construit qui
contribue à fabriquer la loi et dans ce
rôle Gérard Larcher qui est au fond une
sorte d'antiacron parce que il est il
est l'homme des territoires un cors rond
alors que Macron est plutôt quelqu'un
d'un peu d'un peu tranchant c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire de de
Jupiterrien et à qui on a beaucoup
reproché d'oublier les territoires il
est l'antimacron et il est en même temps
son complément et éventuellement celui
avec lequel on peut on peut dialoguer on
peut essayer de trouver des compromis
des convergences avec lequel on peut
construire donc je trouve qu'il est à
l'image du rôle qui est aujourd'hui
celui du Sénat il colle parfaitement
avec cette image là et c'est ce qui fait
de lui je pense un personnage qui est
particulièrement important dans cette
période là alors on parle du personnage
de Gerard arché on va se pencher aussi
un petit peu et bien sur sur son
histoire et notamment depuis qu'il
préside le Sénat depuis donc 2008 Samia
de chir vous brosse son portrait
regardez
c'est une aventure qui démarre en 2008 à
59 ans Gérard Larcher qui occupe alors
son 3è mandat de sénateur se présente à
la présidence du Sénat j'ai beaucoup
reçu de cette maison j'ai envie de lui
donner dans un hémicycle dominé par la
droite le sénateur des ivelines s'impose
logiquement face au candidat socialiste
Jean-Pierre belle 3 ans plus tard mêmes
adversaires et cette fois la tendance
s'inverse le Sénat bascule à gauche pour
la première fois de son histoire Gérard
larch est battu parthse sera de courte
durée en 2014 il redevient président du
Sénat il lance rapidement une réforme de
la chambre haute lutte contre
l'absentéisme et limitation du temps de
parole il faut que nous donnions au
Sénat plus de force que nous fassions
entendre sa voix que cette question
lancinante sur l'utilité d'une assemblée
ne nous soit plus posée en 2017 Gérard
Larcher est largement réélu dans un
Sénat où les macronistes n'ont pas
réussi à s'imposer alors qu'il viennent
de conquérir l'Assemblée nationale c'est
la voix des territoires qui s'est
exprimé ils ont clairement affiché leur
volonté de voir exister un contrepouvoir
parlementaire un an plus tard l'affaire
benala conforte le Sénat dans son rôle
de contrepouvoir face à la majorité
présidentielle un rôle qui se renforce
avec l'arrivée du covid en France le
gouvernement légifère largement par
ordonnance Gérard Larché dénonce la mise
sous cloche du Parlement fin 2020 il est
candidat pour la 4e fois à la présidence
du Sénat qu'il remporte triomphalement
cette élection à la présidence du Sénat
est un honneur et c'est pour moi comme
au premier jour durant ce dernier mandat
les relations se réchauffent avec
l'Élysée privé de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale Emmanuel Macron a besoin de la
droite sénatoriale pour faire adopter
ses
réformes Pascal Perin on vient de voir
donc la trajectoire de jarardarcher
notamment depuis qu'il préside le Sénat
depuis 2008 Jean garc disait à l'instant
l'image de Gérard arché c'est aussi
celle du Sénat aujourd'hui sa longévité
elle est aussi propre au Sénat cette
chambre du temps long oui tout à fait si
vous voulez c'est l'homme d'un
enracinement et d'un enracinement très
très fort euh Gérard Larché et ce Sénat
par rapport à l'Assemblée nationale a
beaucoup plus au-delà du président
d'hommes et de femmes enraciné dans leur
territoire que l'Assemblée nationale et
comme l'Assemblée nationale on disait
tout à l'heure n'a plus de majorité
absolue il y a une sorte presque de
transfert de légitimité de l'Assemblée
nationale vers le Sénat hein les
Français jettent euh sur le Sénat se
pose plus la question de à quoi ça sert
euh le Sénat parce qu'il le voit et euh
tout à l'heure Gérard Larché disait que
il avait envie de rendre au Sénat ce que
le Sénat lui avait apporté mais il a
beaucoup apporté euh depuis euh sa
présidence il a beaucoup apporté au
Sénat il a fait évoluer l'image de
l'assemblée il il
a il a très vite compris en 2022 la
place objective que cette majorité
relative pour les macronistes à
l'Assemblée nationale offrait pour le
Sénat et il a trouvé sa place et quelque
part maintenant dans le duo président de
la République président du Sénat Gérard
Larcher est véritablement essentiel et
peut-être très utile peut-être très
utile on se rappelle quelques mois on
murmurait que Gérard Larcher était un
bon candidat pour Matignon alors chaque
chose en son temps pour l'instant c'est
surtout un bon candidat pour le plateau
mais qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire bien
toutes ces tous ces bruits hein quand
même qu'il a eu autour de Gérard Larcher
oui al tandis que VO pardon Gérard arché
également dans l'hémicycle le le le le
président du Sénat et sénateur des
divelines qui vient d'être réélu que
l'on voit là dans qui va être à sa place
dans l'hémicycle he pas encore sur le
plateau Jean-Baptiste foret écoutez moi
je suis pas dans le secret des dieux
mais évidemment pour Emmanuel Macron ce
serait une une belle carte le débauchage
de de Gérard Larché mais on en est quand
même pas là le personnage Gérard Larcher
il occupe une position centrale parce
qu'il sait aussi réaliser un certain
nombre d'accords entre des forces qui
peuvent paraître divergentes c'est que
avec l'Union centriste qui est quand
même ici au Sénat en grande partie r
allé à la macronie et puis avec un Bruno
rotillo qui aujourd'hui est président du
groupe LR au Sénat qui incarne quand
même plutôt la la la droite de la droite
et c'est un peu le l'entregent de Gard
de Gérard Larcher qui qui qui qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il occupe une position
centrale pas seulement vis-à-vis de ces
groupes mais vis-à-vis d'autres groupes
parce que il est très très difficile
dans cette maison de trouver quelqu'un
qui en dit du mal et oui oui c'est très
compliqué effectivement et compris au
niveau des des oppositions effectivement
gerérard Larcher il un rôle qui n'est
pas si simple he finalement parce parce
que c'est une forme de de ciment entre
des familles politiques qui ne sont pas
toujours sur la même longueur d'onde et
on va le voir d'ailleurs ça sera très
clair certainement sur le projet de loi
immigration Jean Garg exactement il y a
un jeu extrêmement subti qui doit se
jouer entre
l'éventualité de faire des accords au
cas par cas avec le l'exécutif avec le
gouvernement de d'Élisabeth borne et les
intérêts à la fois électoraux et à long
terme de sa famille politique les
républicains et effectivement vous vous
avez cité Bruno rotaillot on voit très
bien en somme que d'un côté vous avez
Emmanuel Macron Édouard Philippe mais de
l'autre côté vous avez aussi éic cioti à
l'Assemblée nationale et et Bruno
rotillot chez les républicains et
d'ailleurs ce le texte qui va venir sur
sur l'immigration dont on a parlé avec
Roger carucci va être un test de cette
capacité de Gérard Larcher à essayer de
trouver justement une médiation un point
d'équilibre libre entre ces deux
intérêts qui sont en réalité
contradictoires parce que si les
républicains pensent à l'avenir et à une
candidature potentielle à la à
l'élection présidentielle qui reste le
rendez-vous majeur pour les Français ça
n'est pas dans cette direction là
forcément qu'il qu'il pourrait aller
alors là c'est là que toute l'habileté
de de Gérard archer va se déployer alors
il est bientôt 15h c'est l'heure de
rejoindre Mathias Arz dans l'hémicycle
Mathias car le président de séance d'un
jour le doyen du Sénat devrait bientôt
s'exprimer ça y est Jean-Marie van
lerenberg qui va bientôt arriver il va
siéger au plateau vous l'avez dit il va
être président le temps d'une séance le
sénateur du P decalais 84 ans doyen de
cette nouvelle assemblée et président du
bureau d' va donc prendre la parole
d'une minute à l'autre un discours qui
se voudra solennel sur le rôle du Sénat
et son implantation sur les territoires
c'est assez raccord avec le discours
qu'il avait tenu ici même il y a 3 ans
Jean-Marie vanlerenberg qui a assuré
avec une pointe d'humour aux équipes de
Public Sénat qu'il serait un petit peu
plus court qu'il y a 3 ans on s'en
souvient Tom c'était un discours qui
avait duré un petit peu plus de 20
minutes on l'attend donc maintenant
d'une minute à l'autre ici dans
l'hémicycle merci merci beaucoup Mathias
ah oui ben quand on préside la séance un
jour on peut aussi avoir le droit d'en
profiter un petit peu pour adresser
quelques messages et tandis que l'on
voit également et bien cette galerie des
bustes et au fond de cette galerie des
bustes on voit le cabinet de départ d'où
va donc sortir ce bureau d'âge he c'est
un moment on le disait Pascal Perino
très solennel un moment quand même assez
important et qui ouvre aussi et bien la
session parlementaire qui ouvre aussi
les hostilités tout à fait et cette
session parlementaire elle va être
extrêmement importante et certainement
très animée et il faut réconcilier les
Français avec la logique parlementaire
parce que euh le spectacle offert par
l'Assemblée nationale depuis son
élection de l'été 2022 exaspère les
français si vous voulez cette Assemblée
nationale transformée en espèce de grand
guignol ça lasse tout le monde hein
parce que très peu de choses se de se
disent euh on a l'impression de d'une
partie du personnel parlementaire en
effet qui est dans la posture
perpétuelle et dans l'excès perpétuel on
sa qu'il y a même des débats aujourd'hui
à l'Assemblée hein pour savoir s'il faut
pas s'opposer d'une façon un peu un peu
plus dig un peu plus digne un peu plus
institutionnalisé et le Sénat on le voit
avec ce qui se passe aujourd'hui le
Sénat lui a toujours joué même dans les
moments les plus chauds de la 5e
République a toujours su garder raison a
su garder une dignité républicaine et au
fond ce sont les dispositifs de cette
dignité républicaine à laquelle on
assiste et je crois que les Français ont
besoin de cela pour pour recroire à
nouveau à leurs institutions et à la
République je on s'arrête un instant sur
cette image on entend la sonnerie qui
retentit et on va voir s'avancer on les
voit cela commence he voilà les deux
huissiers qui précède le bureau d'âge
avec et bien le doyen du Sénat c le
sénateur de pcalais âgé de 84 ans
Jean-Marie van lurenberg qui fait son
entrée vous le voyez qui vient d'être
réélu d'ailleurs Jean-Marie van lenberg
dans le P de Calais il est accompagné
des six sénateurs les plus jeunes de
cette assemblée Mathilde Olivier la
benjamine du Sénat âgé de 29 ans mais
aussi Rémy Cardon Alexandre wiouisille
Sébastien Fagan et Joshua auchochard
enfin Audrey bellim voilà ils sont en
train d'arriver Jean-Marie van lurenberg
va arriver sur le le plateau après avoir
traversé la galerie des bustes le voilà
qui
s'installe devant vous le voyez cet
hémicycle qui est comble séance est
ouverte monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues vous pouvez vous
asseoir
[Musique]
je je salue si vous
permettez c'est la rentrée je sais bien
mais bon euh un petit peu de silence
s'il vous plaît je salue les six plus
jeunes sénateurs présents qui rempliront
lors de cette séance les fonctions de
secrétaire d'âge et les invite à siéger
à mes côtés au bureau
alors je les appelle madame Mathilde
Olivier sénatrice sénatrice
représentante les Français établis hors
de
France Rémy Cardon sénateur de la
somme c'est déjà un
[Applaudissements]
ancienre
ise monsieur Sébastien Fanen sénateur de
la
Manche monsieur Josua auchard sénateur
du
Nord et Madame Audrey bellim sénatrice
de la
Réunion
en application de l'article 28 de la
Constitution la session ordinaire
2023-2024 est
ouverte alors j'ai reçu la communication
de la liste des sénateurs programmé élu
le 24 septembre 2023 et acte est donné
de cette
communication alors si vous me permettez
avant de procéder à ce que vous attendez
tous c'est-à-dire l'élection du
président
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues c'est la seconde fois que j'ai
l'honneur de présider cette séance au
privilège de
l'âge et à ce titre je voudrais vous
livrer une
recette je n'ai jamais été autant
médiatisé depuis que je suis réélu à
l'âge de 84
ans d'autant plus que ma fille nouvelle
élue siège aussi parmi nous alors avis
aux
amateurs plus
sérieusement mes premiers mots sont pour
présenter mes sincères et chaleureuses
félicitations à l'ensemble des
sénatrices et sénateurs nouvellement
élus
ou réélu dimanche dernier je leur
souhaite évidemment la bienvenue au sein
de notre assemblée j'ai aussi une pensée
particulière pour toutes celles et tous
ceux qui ne siégeront plus parmi nous
soit parce qu'ils n'ont pas souhaité se
représenter soit parce qu'ils n'ont pas
été reconduits qu' soi remerciés de
leurs action constructive dans tous les
domaines de la qualité de leur travail
et de la participation à nos
débats le Sénat a ses règles ses codes
son ambiance plus fautrait que celle de
l'Assemblée nationale surtout en ce
moment un ancien et célèbre sénateur et
je pense que certains vont le
reconnaître disait à l'Assemblée
nationale on tue avec le poignard au
Sénat on empoisonne avec le
sourire loin des turbulences du Palais
Bourbon souvent soumis au souousbressau
de l'actualité la Haute Assemblée reste
un espace de stabilité dans nos
institutions où l'on sait que la
politique c'est l'art du
compromis mais le Sénat ne vit pas moins
intensément le débat il a toujours su
faire place à la confrontation et au
respect des idées il est garant de notre
démocratie et il fabrique la loi souvent
de façon plus subtile et peut-être plus
réaliste nous sommes avant tout des
parlementaires et dans un régime qui l'
de moins en moins le contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement et l'évaluation
des politiques publiques sont plus que
jamais
essentielles alors je reste
personnellement un partisan acharné du
dialogue constructif de la
cononstruction des lois avec le
gouvernement et l'Assemblée nationale
bien sûr avec des députés qui
malheureusement ne comprennent pas
toujours que ce qui leur reste de
pouvoir se trouve dans le dialogue avec
nous c'est une manière de rendre le
bicamérisme
vivant car il est un antidote à toute
forme de populisme et d'extrémisme
ces mots qui menacent la cohésion
sociale et la construction européenne
les ingénieurs de ce chaos sont à
l'œuvre il est urgent d'enrayer la
machine à détruire la
démocratie et face à cette
menace il nous faut me semble-t-il
mobiliser en priorité les élus locaux
ceux qui sont en première ligne ce que
j'appellerai l'armée de la République du
quotidien qui se sentent parfois
incompris ou délaissés et dont nous
sommes ici les
représentants le rôle du Sénat est donc
plus que jamais en tant qu'assemblée des
territoires de relever les défis qui
nous
entoure la fracture territoriale la
perte d'autonomie fiscale l'empilement
des normes la transition énergétique la
sécurité et j'en
passe je ne doute pas que la somme des
talents et de compétences d'expérience
dans not dans notre assemblée
renouvelée apportera beaucoup à la
fabrication de la loi et à la résolution
de ces enjeux majeurs avec le courage de
la nuance dont parlait Albert Camu bien
loin des facilités de l'outrance voilà
mes chers collègues l'heure n'est plus à
la mise en cause de l'existence du Sénat
dieu merci bien au contraire
tout le monde aujourd'hui a pris
conscience que lorsqu'une assemblée
boîte ou vacille l'autre apporte
l'équilibre indispensable au bon
fonctionnement de nos institutions alors
par gros temps faut de bon marin et vous
en êtes mes chers collègues et un bon
capitaine nous l'avons alors donc sans
tarder passons à l'élection du capitaine
oh pardon du président
merci
voilà pour le discours de Jean-Marie van
lorenberg le doyen du Sénat et on va
retrouver mathiasz qui se trouve dans la
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle Mathias
car maintenant qu'est-ce qui va se
passer écoutez il a tenu parole
Jean-Marie van lenberg il a tenu un
discours de 5 minutes c'est bien plus
court que il y a 3 ans les sénateurs
dispose d'ors et déjà des bulletins sur
leur pupitre quatre bulletins au total
celui de Gérard Larcher président
sortant celui de Cécile cuckerman pour
les communistes celui de Patrick caner
pour les socialistes et enfin celui de
Guillaume Gontard pour les écologistes
alors à l'appel de leur nom deux options
s'offrent au au sénateur pour le vote
soit ils décident de mettre le bulletin
de leur candidat dans l'enveloppe
directement à leur place soit il passent
par l'isoloire qui qui est derrière
raage mailde Olivier sénatrice des
Français établ de France r Cardon
sénateur de la Somme scrutin qui va
durer 1 heure seraensuite transportter
jusque dans la salle des conféren merci
Maas mais on va rejoindre tout de suite
le plateau parce que on entend encore
jeanmexpre va écouter quandme la
discours pardon à superviser ces
opérations de
vote alors mes chers collègues des
bulletin de vote et une enveloppe ont
été déposé sur votre pupitre vous serez
invité à voter à la
tribune en remettant votre enveloppe au
à la plus jeune secrétaire d'âge qui la
placera elle-même dans
l'urne je rappelle que vous pourrez
voter à l'appel de votre nom ou de celui
de votre délégant
des isolois ont été installés pour ceux
qui le souhaitent l'un au pied de la
tribune et l'autre en salle des
conférences il va être procédé donc à
l'appel nominal de vos de nos collègues
en en appelant tout d'abord ce dont le
nom commence par une lettre tirée au
sort il sera ensuite procédé à un nouvel
appel des sénateurs qui n'auront pas
répondu au premier il rappel de leur nom
je vais tirer au sort cette lettre par
laquelle nous commençons
u
ah ça fait des
heureux et d'autres
moins voilà
c'est vraiment une assemblée
dissipée nous avons aujourd'hui ça doit
être le
temps le scrutin pour l'élection du
président du Sénat est ouvert sera cl
évidemment quelques instants après
l'appel nominal messieurs les huissers
veillez commencer l'appel s'il vous
plaît
lettre lettre lettre
monsieuren
lettre V madame Valente
Leir retrouve à l'instant donc Mathias
Mathias ares dans l'émicycle du Sénat
Mathias car c'est donc la lettre U qui a
été tiré dans cette sémicyle un peu
dissipée nous a dit Jean-Marie lenberg a
une ambance de de rentrer des classes
dans votre hémicycle Mathias oui il y a
beaucoup de de bruit hein dans cet
hémicycle vous avez entendu les réaction
à l'annonce du tirage de cette lettre U
c'est donc Simon huzna sénateur du
morbillant qui votera en premier et à
l'inverse si on respecte bien l'ordre
c'est Jean-Claude tisso qui votera en
dernier alors pour vous refaire un petit
peu les modalités les sénateurs ont déjà
sur leur pupitre les quatre bulletin de
vote ils peuvent soit les mettre dans
l'enveloppe et directement passer ici à
la tribune pour donc la mettre dans l'
soit ils peuvent passer exactement aussi
dans l'isoloir si il le désir voilà un
vote qui se réalise sous le contrôle de
la benjamine de cet hémicycle Mathilde
Olivier merci beaucoup Mathias et on va
rejoindre Quentin calm qui se trouve
dans la salle des conférences qui juste
l'hémicycle Quentin car c'est là qu'il y
a et bien les isoloirs c'est aussi là
que vont être dépouillés ensuite les
bulletins de vote exactement quand les
348 sénateurs auront été appelés qu'ils
auront voté en tribune les urnes vont
être l'urnne va être ensuite acheminé
ici c'est sur ces trois tables qui se
trouvent en salle des conférences que le
dépouillement va avoir lieu avant d'être
proclamé dans l'enceinte de l'hémicycle
l'opération devrait durer 1h 1h30 t on
surverra ça de très près on va voir donc
au fur et à mesure l'hémicycle se videré
la salle des conférences se reremplir
avec tous les sénateurs qui auront déjà
voté on va pouvoir comme ça ça aussi et
bien tendre notre micro à tous ces
sénateurs ici depuis la salle des
conférences Tam vous attendez ça avec
impatience he pour avoir de nouveaux
invités Quentin jean-gar je vous donne
la parole vous devez malheureusement
nous quitter d'ici quelques minutes mais
je voulais quand même vous faire réagir
à l'une à l'un des propos de Jean-Marie
vanlerender qui a dit à l'Assemblée on
tue avec le poignard au Sénat on
empoisonne avec le sourire c'est plus
feutré il peut y avoir des débats et ça
peut mettre même être sanglant ah ça
peut être sanglant d'ailleurs les les
les commissions d'enquête qui ont remis
un peu en lumière le Sénat depuis
quelques depuis quelques temps ont été
comment dire caractérisés par une une
sévérité une rigueur hein qui qui fait
partie de de la vie politique aussi mais
c'est vrai que les choses se passent de
manière plus feutrée et et donc offre au
français un spectacle beaucoup plus
digne que celui de l'Assemblée nationale
et par les temps qui court où il faut on
est en recherche d'une légitimité
nouvelle de nos institutions c'est très
important de garder ce ce caractère
feutré modéré digne mais même si les
combats politiques peuvent être
extrêmement violents si les les les
dissensus peuvent être très forts mais
on garde on le fait avec la la
modération et la dignité qui Cie à une
Assemblée du peuple c'est vrai
Jean-Baptiste fet que l'un des
événements marquants notamment depuis
queemmanuel Macron est président de la
République c'est le pouvoir de contrôle
du Sénat queon a pu voir à travers
plusieurs commissions d'enquête de
l'affaire benala à celle récemment du
fond Mariane et qui a d'ailleurs valu et
bien
la la sortie finalement de marlè Chapa
lors du remanement de l'été dernier oui
il y a eu un certain nombre d'enquêtes
je pense aussi à l'enquête sur le le
fiasco du stade du Stade de France ces
enquêtes là ont vu apparaître au grand
jour des personnages que ne connaissaz
pas les Français je pense à quelqu'un
comme Philippe Bas à quelqu'un comme
Jean-Pierre Sueur qui ne correspondent
pas forcément au au canon télévisuel
actuel mais qui finalement un peu comme
Gérard Larcher ont ont acquis une
certaine une certaine aura on a vu que
c'était des des hommes de loi implaca
qui menaient leur leur enquête jusqu'au
bout en dehors des des contingences
politiciennes je voudrais juste apporter
un petit un petit complément à ce que
vous disiez sur le le Sénat le poison
sur la question que vous posiez parce il
paraît qu'au Sénat les les moquettes
sont rouges notamment comme dans la
salle des conférence pour ne pas voir
les traces de sang c'est ça voilà il y a
beaucoup de soir effectivement sur les
coulisses du Sénat le palais de marine
Medicis merci beaucoup jeangaric d'avoir
été avec nous je vous libère et on va
tout de suite rejoindre Quentin qui se
trouve avec le président du groupe Union
centriste qui vient d'être réélu aussi
c'est le sénateur Hervé Marseille
bonjour her marseil bonjour les votes le
vote qui a commencé effectivement dans
la salle dans l'hémicycle le scrutin il
est sans suspense vous le dites
effectivement à notre micro Gérard
Larchet devrait être élu pour la 5e fois
au Plateau écoutez à partir du moment où
les deux groupes qui forment la majorité
sénatoriale forment un même vote en
faveur du président sortant on peut
imaginer qu'il soit élu dès le premier
tour c'est ça il y a eu des fois où les
centristes ont présenté un candidat je
crois que c'était madame lettard à
l'époque ne serait-ce que pour se
compter aussi voir combien ils étaient
dans l'hémicyclle Pourquoi est-ce que
vous l'avez pas fait cette année c'était
évident le pacte de la majorité de la
droite et du centre au Sénat il devait
repartir pour 3 ans écoutez euh on a
effectivement euh
un accord entre nous au sein de la
majorité sénatoriale et puis surtout
j'allais dire qu'il y a un accord aussi
moral avec le président qui prend en
compte toutes les sensibilités de sa
majorité avec lequel on travaille de
façon extrêmement étroite et donc il y
avait aucune raison de marquer une
différence qu'est-ce qu'il symbolise
Gérard lcher à vos yeux dans le paysage
politique actuel déjà on peut dire c'est
une forme de continuité qu'est-ce que
vous vous voyez avec cette réélection
d'abord l'affirmation de la place du
Sénat il incarne il symbolise j'allais
dire la place du Sénat dans les
institutions Sénat qui a retrouvé un
poids supplémentaire par l'absence de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
le point d'équilibre ici euh des
institutions
et on a une responsabilité c'est de
faire en somme en en pardon on a une
responsabilité c'est de faire en sorte
que les institutions fonctionnent et que
les textes qui passent ici au Sénat
puissent être examinés et sortir pour
être présentés à l'assemblée le groupe
LR devrait perdre 10 sénateurs avec ce
renouvellement qui a lieu le 24
septembre on voit que les centristes
vous devriez garder le même nombre de
sénateurs 57 si je ne me trompe pas il y
a des élus Macron compatibles à droite
qui vont voilà intégrer le groupe de de
Monsieur maluré est-ce que l'équilibre
politique du Sénat va changer avec le 24
septembre selon vous écoutez il y a un
rééquilibrage au sein de la
majorité mais j'allais dire il y a
toujours une majorité elle est stable
elle est solide et puis il y a une
opposition et donc à partir de là je
pense que les débats vont continuer
comme ils étaient auparavant
c'est-à-dire de façon extrêmement
positive et je l'ai dit de façon
responsable parce que vis-à-vis de
l'Assemblée nationale on a aujourd'hui
une responsabilité supplémentaire la
majorité de la droite et du centre au
Sénat est-elle dans l'opposition
Emmanuel Macron au président de la
République je crois qu'il s'agit pas de
d'être en opposition avec qui que ce
soit il s'agit simplement d'examiner les
textes de les de faire en sorte qu'il
soit viable pour être présenté à
l'assemblée et euh j'allais dire ce
qu'il faut c'est surtout être utile au
pays et faire en sorte que les textes
qui nous soit présenté et bien soit
modifié soit travaillé et voté comme on
l'a fait pour les retraites un dernier
mot très court si vous me le permettez
le prochain projet de loi important qui
devrait arriver au Sénat c'est le projet
de loi immigration on voit que vous êtes
pas sur la même longueur d'onde avec vos
collègues LR vous vous parlez peut-être
de passer par du réglementaire sur
l'article 3 sur les titres de séjour
dans les métiers en tenstion eux ne
semblent pas vouloir de la mesure du
tout est-ce qu'il va pas y avoir un
premier sujet de discorde dans les
prochaines semaines entre la majorité
les camp de la majorité sénatoriale non
on a des différences et chacun les
assume he le texte est déjà passé en
commission des lois il y a plusieurs
mois 95 % du texte a été adopté avec des
modifications il y a un article un seul
dont on a fait un article fétiche
l'article 3 sur la
régularisation gens voilà dans les
métiers en tenstion c'est peu de choses
c'est peu de gens on va trouver une
solution qu'on avait déjà esquissé en
commission des lois je ne doute pas que
d'ici le mois de novembre on a encore du
temps on trouve ensemble la solution et
bien merci merci mer pour cette réaction
à notre micro je vous laisse rejoindre
l'miss parceque vous n'avez pas encore
voté vu qu'on a commencé à la lettre U
merci beaucoup merci merci beaucoup
Quentin et oui effectivement il paraît
qu'on en est à peu près à la lettre B un
mot sur la façon dont est sorti hein le
Sénat du 24 septembre on a dit bon dans
l'ensemble une grande St abilité une
majorité qui reste à droite et au centre
mais quand même une légère érosion du
groupe LR on voit le groupe les
indépendants qui grossit un petit peu on
voit aussi le retour quand même de
sénateur rassemblement national au sein
de l'hémicycle auquel leçon en tiré pour
vous Pascal Perino alors la leçon c'est
tout de même la stabilité euh le Sénat
reste à la droite et au centre bien euh
et peut jouer donc pleinement son rôle
d'équilibre et son rôle de de
contrepouvoir mais euh à la fois au sein
de la gauche et de la droite il y a des
évolutions au sein de la droite oui il y
a eu une légère usure euh des
républicains qui ont perdu environ 10
sénateurs faut dire que c'était le
groupe le plus important donc5 il serait
à 135 136 voilà voilà il sera à 135 136
on verra ce qu'il en est ce soir quand
les effectifs des groupes seront
stabilisé euh il y a une très bonne
résistance de l'Union centriste qui n'a
pas a
subi la légère sanction qu'a pu subir LR
et puis il y a cette étonnante poussée
que certains n'avaient pas vu venir du
groupe des indépendants présidé par
Claude maluret parce que au fond on
s'aperçoit que autant la la macronie a
été sanctionnée puisque là ils ont perdu
ils avaient déjà des petits effectifs
mais ils ont perdu nettement euh mais il
y a eu la naissance de de ce courant
horizon et horizon qui a été créé par
Édouard philippe est un mouvement
contrairement à la macronique est un
mouvement un parti d'élus locaux et donc
voilà il était inévitable que horizon
fasse un relatif succès et comme les
députés d'horizon les h sénateurs pardon
d'horizon ont choisi de se rattacher aux
indépendants ce groupe a connu une
vigueur qui n'avait pas connu auparavant
les socialistes et bien tiennent tienent
correctement mais il n'arrivent pas à
repartir à renouer avec la dynamique la
dynamique est plutôt du côté de leur
partenair à la fois du côté des
écologistes qui ont engrangé beaucoup
d'élus locaux dans les grandes
métropoles dans les grandes villes
aujourd'hui il y a Bordeaux tour tout
cela Lyon s dirigé hein par des maires
écologistes et donc il y a derrière
beaucoup d'élus locaux écologistes et
donc les écologistes ont connu une une
croissance qui devrait amener les
effectifs aux alentours de 17 peut-être
18 euh sénateurs et puis le groupe
communiste et où là il y a véritablement
un contrepied parce que les observateurs
s'attendaient à une érosion des
communistes non il y a eu une légère
poussée des communistes de 15 euh à 17
c'est dû aussi au fait que les
communistes ont joué assez habilement
des stratégies dans les départements
d'union de la gauche et donc c'était le
candidat était certes le candidat
communiste mais c'était avant tout le
candidat d'union de la gauche et il a
bénéficié bien sûr du vote des
socialistes des élus locaux socialistes
et des élus locaux vert qui ont fait la
victoire de cette communiste prenons par
exemple celle qui préside au destiné du
du du groupe communiste madameerman oui
qui effectivement se présente d'ailleurs
au plateau Jean-Baptiste foret c'est
intéressant on voit au Sénat perdurer
aussi voilà des des des des tendances en
miroir inversé j'allais dire de
l'Assemblée nationale avec bien
l'absence totale de la France insoumise
le rassemblement national il ils sont
encore très peu il n'y a que trois
sénateurs élu effectivement certains
partis anciens très ancrés qui
continuent à perdurer au Sénat oui bah
c'est un peu la revanche de l'Ancien
Monde en quelque sorte le le Sénat avec
un parti socialiste vous l'avez dit qui
qui perd quelques quelques sièges mais
ça reste quand même à la marge qui
caractérise quand même avant tout ce
crrutin c'est quand même une grande
habilité néanmoins il y a quelques
signaux faibles qui peuvent être repérés
ben je pense notamment à ces trois
sénateurs Ren en fait on voit des petits
maires je mets beaucoup de guillemets à
à à à petit bah être aussi un peu à
l'image de la population française dans
un certain nombre de départements ruraux
je pense en particulier à la cemarne qui
est un peu un département
d'ortoire de de la région parisienne il
y avait déjà eu un député rassemblement
national en 2022 maintenant il y a euh
une personnalité qui qui représente le
rassemblement national
ici ici même et puis on voit
effectivement cette poussée des
écologistes dans dans les grandes dans
les grandes métropoles dans les grands
centres urbains et d'ailleurs ça
pourrait peut-être poser un jour la
question bah du du mode de scrutin
c'est-à-dire que la France rurale reste
quand même très très représentée enfin
vous l'avez dit c'est l'essence du du
Sénat mais évidemment les écologistes
souhaiteraient un un rééquilibrage en
faveur des des urbain euh une digue à
sauté pour vous sur la question du
rassemblement national parce qu'on on on
ne le voit pas du tout au niveau du
chiffr on a que il y a que trois
sénateurs RN mais on sait qu'il y a
quand même plus de grands électeurs qui
ont voté avir en eff une analyse nuancée
première constatation ça n'est pas la
première fois qu'il y a des sénateurs du
RN il y a déjà eu des sénateurs du RN
deuxième constatation au-delà de
l'élection de trois sénateurs deux
étaient assez attendus en effet en cemar
c'était moins attendu et là c'est la
sociologie de ce département qui quelque
part s'est exprimé la fracture
territoriale de ces banlieux très
périphérique voilà ça ça aussi une
manifestation politique et et le
sénateur qui a été élu en cén pour le RN
représente assez bien cette fracture
mais au-delà des sénateurs il y a les
électeurs sénatoriaux et là c'est très
frappant de voir que dans de multiples
départements où ils ont fait de bons
scores les candidats du bien sûr ils
n'ont pas d'élus parce que ce sont par
exemple des départements où on vote au
majoritaire au majoritaires à deux tours
mais parfois ils ont fait 14 15 17 % des
voix d'électeurs sénatoriaux sans avoir
de sénateur hein parce qu'on est dans un
scrutin majoritaire donc oui il y a
au-delà de ces trois il y a un signal
oui que je n'ose pas dire oui un signal
faible de quelque chose de plus profond
c'est-à-dire que en effet comme cela
vient dit euh les électeurs sénatorux
c'est des Français comme les autres et
ils sont oui soumis à cette poussé à
cette légitimité croissante qu'à le
rassemblement national sur dans les
territoires français est-ce que cela va
aussi de per Jean-Baptiste foret avec
certain nombre de sénateurs qui nous
disaient il y a une forme de de
dépolitisation des de certains élus
locaux aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup plus
de sens à faire campagne aujourd'hui on
peut dans une même majorité par exemple
dans une mairie voter pour différents
courants et cetera est-ce que c'est
aussi dans Ceel que ça peut s'inscrire
alors je sais pas si c'est une question
de de politisation mais c'est une
question je dirais de de vassalité en
quelque sorte c'estàd qu'on avait des
des sénateurs qui étaient vraiment les
grands élus de leur département il
présidaient d'ailleurs souvent au
destinés de leur de leur conseil général
ils avaient un certain nombre de maires
qui étaient parfois leurs anciens ateur
donc on avait des systèmes politiques
locaux qui étaient très installés et
finalement à la faveur de la fin du
cumul des mandats en 2017 le jeu c'est
beaucoup plus ouvert et ça a permis à
d'autres personnalités d'entrer sur ces
sur ces scènes politiques locales je
pense que pour ce qui est aussi du du
rassemblement national il y a aussi des
motifs de de crispation propre aux élus
locaux propre aussi au débat autour de
l'écologie je pense à deux deux thèmes
dont on on parle beaucoup ces derniers
ces derniers mois je pense au zéro
artificialisation net alors c'est un
terme très très Mar qui veut dire
bétonnisation c'est-à-dire qu'un certain
nombre de M créent qui a plus de
pavillon individuels qui puissent plus
construire du tout dans leur commune
donc ça ça suscite énormément de de de
de crispation on a vu que Laurent
voquier qui chasse en partie sur les
terres du rassemblement national tirer à
boulet rouge ce weekend contre ce ce
dispositif il a même dit qu'il
l'appliquerait pas chez lui en en Ronal
par je vous interrompes parce que on
voit Cécile Kerman c'est la nouvelle
présidente du groupe communiste qui
vient de voter Cécile cuckerman qui est
elle-même et bien candidate au plateau
et qui représente donc le groupe
communiste un groupe vous le disiez
Pascal Perino qui est plutôt sorti
renforcé contre toute attente de cette
élection Pascal Perino on parlait élus
locaux à l'instant difficile aussi de ne
pas parler et bien du malaise de de ces
élus on sort d'une période qui a été
très compliquée pour eux entre les
violences auxqueles ils ont dû faire
face les émeutes aussi qu'on a pu voir
notamment à l'été ces sénateurs ils
représentent aussi des élus qui sont
dans une situation compliquée difficile
sonent pas toujours respecté bien vu des
Français aujourd'hui tout à fait les
élus locaux ce sont véritablement les
fantassins de la République c'est eux
qui prennent les coups si vous voulez
qui parfois sont destinés à d'autres
parce que si vous prenez l'image des
mères en France dans toutes les enquêtes
c'est la seule qui est vraiment positive
largement au-dessus de 50 % mais on voit
bien les exaspérations les colères des
Français les ressentiments de certains
peuvent s'exprimer en prenant à parti
l'homme ou la femme qui est la plus
proche de vous et leslut de proximité
c'est en effet le maire ou tel ou tel
conseil municipau conseiller municipal
mais enfin surtout le maire et il y a eu
en effet une tendance à l'agression de
plus en plus fréquente des maires en
tant que représentant de la République
c'est un acte grave qui doit être
j'allais dire sévèrement sévèrement
sanctionné afin de stopper ce mouvement
qui qui est véritablement dégradant pour
la culture républicaine française et
bien merci merci beaucoup à tous les
deux d'avoir et bien commencé à
commenter cette élection du président du
Sénat avec nous Pascal ino je rappelle
votre livre le vote clivé les élections
présidentielles et législatives d'avril
et juin 2022 au Pug les presse
universitaire de Grenoble et
Jean-Baptiste foret je rappelle votre
livre également au cœur du Grand
déclassement la fierté perdue de Peugeot
Soo aux éditions du SER et tout de suite
on va se rendre salle des conférences on
va rejoindre Quentin Calmet qui se
trouve avec la sénatrice écologiste des
Français de l'étranger Mélanie Vogel
Vogel bonjour Merci d'être au micro de
Public Sénat cet après-midi qu'est-ce
qui se joue dans l'hémicycle il y a il y
a de l'enjeu politique selon vous dans
dans ce qui se joue cet après-midi ben
il y a quand même une chose qu'on peut
remarquer c'est que mis à part la
candidature de Gérard Larcher qui n'est
évidemment pas une surprise et l'issue
du vote n'est pas non plus une surprise
les seules candidatures qui sont
opposées à la candidature de Gérard
arché ce sont les trois candidatures de
gauche vous avezcologist communiste et
socialistes and exactement euh nous
remarquons donc que la majorité
présidentielle bien qu'officiellement
officiellement dans l'opposition au
Sénat n'a pas présenté de candidature
contre Gérard Larché que ce soit le
groupe RDP le groupe de François patria
ou la droite Macron compatible de Claude
malur vous vous remarquez
qu'effectivement ces deux groupes n'ont
pas présenté candidat qu'est-ce que ça
signifie à vos yeux voilà bien ça
signifie que manifestement je ne sais
pas à quel point il se considère
réellement dans l'opposition au Sénat
mais manifestement il soutiennent la
candidat de Gérard Larcher puisque il ne
présente pas de candidat contre lui
est-ce que ça dit quelque chose d'un
Sénat de droite qui sera peut-être plus
Macron compatible que par le passé
encore plus peut-être ça dit surtout que
la majorité présidentielle aujourd'hui a
davantage comme objectif comme projet de
collaborer avec les républicains dans un
contexte où nous allons voir l'élection
de Gérard Larcher dans quelques minutes
dans un contexte où les républicains au
niveau national ça ne vous aura pas
échappé représente une minorité de
l'électorat et on a au Sénat une
majorité pour la droite avec le renfort
qui n'est pourtant pas nécessaire de la
majorité présidentielle qu'est-ce que
Gérard Larcher représente à vos yeux on
le dit il devrait faire et bien son
retour au plateau pour une 5e élection
au poste de président du Sénat qu'est-ce
que ce personnage politique représente à
vos yeux B Gérard Larché c'est la la
droite traditionnelle voilà c'est à
l'image de ce qui est le Sénat
aujourd'hui mais le sujet c'est pas
tellement Gérard Larcher lui comme
individu c'est plutôt l'exercice que
nous reproduisons aujourd'hui et que
reproduit cette chambre par son système
électoral par sa
sociologie cet exercice qui est en en
décalage total avec le pays qui est la
France aujourd'hui c'est le scénat
conservateur c'est peut-être aussi le
rôle de contrebalancier de la vie
politique vous le reconnaissez pas ce ce
rôle j'ai pas trop l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui le balancier ils doivent
aller vers plus de conservatisme dans
c'est c'est pas mon impression un mot
sur un symbole mais à la tribune c'est
une sénatrice écologiste la benjamine du
Sénat pouvez-nous dire quelques mots sur
sur Mathilde Olivier que l'on voit en ce
moment en train de récupérer les
bulletins effectivement pour cette voilà
cette élection de président du Sénat bah
d'abord vous dire que c'est une grande
fierté une grande fierté pour moi elle
est élue aussi des Français de
l'étranger une grande fierté pour le
groupe écologiste et c'est un des
apports du groupe écologiste au Sénat
amener de la diversité amener des
profils différents Mathilde Olivier
c'est donc la benjamine vous l'avez dit
elle fait aussi partie de ce qu'on a
appelé la génération climat ces jeunes
qui a 5 ans sont sortis pour demander au
gouvernement d'agir réellement pour le
climat et qui 5 ans après au fond
remarque qu'il n'y a pas eu les actes
qui était pourtendu et qui décide bien
de s'engager et d'arriver aux
responsabilités et c'est un symbole très
important de voir que la génération
climat n'est plus seulement dans la rue
mais elle est aussi dans les
institutions et bien merci merci Mélan
pour cette
réactionro
merci merci beaucoup Quentin et
j'accueille sur ce ce plateau deux
sénateurs qui viennent d'être réélus
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir Sophie
prima bonjour bonjour sénatrice les
républicain des Yvelines face à vous
pierreouas bonjour bonjour à vous
sénateur communiste des hautes scènes
bonjour et félicitations à tous les deux
vous venez d'être réélu Sophie prima
quel est votre état d'exprit en ce début
de session alors que le Sénat vient
d'être renouvelé bon j'imagine que sans
surprise vous allez voter pour Gérard
Larché qui était premier sur votre list
il y a pas de surprise il y aura pas de
surprise non non mais c'est un état
d'esprit euh d'abord je suis évidemment
contente de la réélection de Gérard
lâché dans les Yvelines plus
généralement de notre équipe dans les
Yvelines assz assez large euh je suis
ravie que la majorité sénatoriale puisse
réaffirmer voilà son sa sa majorité
solide mais je suis dans un état
d'esprit extrêmement combatif après
cette campagne où nous avons ressenti
très très fortement le besoin des élus
locaux exprimés par les élus locaux le
besoin d'un Sénat qui soit un sénat
constructif qui soit un sénat qui est la
main qui soit un sénat qui propose et
véritablement pour les élus locaux ça
m'a frappé dans cette campagne à quel
point ce ressenti est fort parmi les
élus locaux donc je suis compative pour
défendre l'institution comme le fait
depuis des années Gérard Larcher mais
peut-être aller encore plus loin le
rendre encore plus moderne encore plus
fluide encore plus agile et en tout cas
le mettre vraiment au cœur de la
démocratie pierre ouia on parlait juste
avant avec nos invités de ce malaise des
élus locaux des difficultés qu'ils ont
eu ces derniers mois ces dernières
années notamment vous qui qui rentrez de
de campagne comment est-ce que vous les
avez sentis pardon pendant que on voit
Guillaume Gontard le président du groupe
écologiste également candidat au plateau
qui vote à l'instant voilà on le disait
le groupe écologiste notamment qui est
sorti renforcé de cette élection pierre
rousouliia oui un petit retour de de de
ce que vous avez ressenti vous en
campagne qu'est-ce que vous avez entendu
moi je suis donc réélu sénateur des haut
scè et sur ma liste il y avait Patrick
Jarry le maire de Nanterre ce qui est un
symbole politique fort important après
les événements de nanter bien sûr après
les événements deair le sentiment des
mères c'est qu'ils sont abandonnés ou
face à des problèmes sociaux qui
deviennent de plus en plus considérable
extrêmement difficile à à gérer et ce
qu'il ce qu'il souhaite c'est plus
d'État chez eux c'est pas moins d'État
hein c'est c'est plus d'État plus de
service public parce qu'il n'y a
qu'avec les services publics qu'on
arrivera à refaire du lien aujourd'hui
on a besoin de faire du lien tandis que
nous accueillons voilà Emmanuel Capu un
sénateur les indépendants de men etoir
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ça va
est-ce que vous avez pu reprendre votre
sou parce que je peux déjà vous poser
une question al tout va bien parce qu'on
parlait à l'instant et bien un petit peu
de l'état d'esprit des élus locaux hein
pour pour Sophie prima pour pour
Monsieur ouia qui tous les deux rentrent
reviennent de campagne vous dans quel
état d'esprit sont les élus locaux
aujourd'hui on les disait parfois un
petit peu démoralisé après des années
compliquées difficiles où ils sentent
pas forcément toujours reconnu et
respecté par les Français je CIS je
crois en sortant de cette campagne qui
s'est bien passé pour moi que les élus
locaux sont
extrêmement en attente d'un rôle
important du Sénat et d'illeurs ils nous
ont tous dit dans la campagne
que on a que le Sénat avrait vraiment
trouvé sa place ces six dernières années
et c'est c'est ça qui ressort très
clairement ensuite il y a plein de
demandes effectivement il y a des
inquiétudes qui sont relevées je pense
qu'on l'a tous relevé sur nos
territoires vis-à-vis par exemple du
statut de l'élu vis-à-vis de
l'inquiétude à trouver de nouveaux élus
qui puissent faire des listes dans 3 ans
maintenant parce que avec les
contraintes de plus en plus de textes
compliqués de plus en plus de temps pris
par les mandats et et une reconnaissance
de la société qui était pas toujours à
la hauteur voire parfois de la violence
physique et verbale c'est ça qui ressort
c'est une demande d'être mieux pris en
compte d'être plus soutenu et d'être
mieux reconnu je crois une nécessité
Sophie Prim effectivement pour que cette
fonction puisse être plus attractive on
a entendu beaucoup de fois le Sénat
aussi qui sonnait l'alarme sur le fait
que et bien ce n'était pas facile d'être
élu local aujourd'hui vous savez le
l'ENT tête du du Salon des Maes du
Congrès des mares l'année dernière
c'était redonner le pouvoir d'agir aux
maires et en fait c'est ça qui blesse
les mères profondément c'est-à-dire que
eux ils ont été élus face à une
population qu'ils ont directement autour
d'eux ils sont vous savez ce ce maillon
de proximité invraisemblable et tout
d'un coup on leur retire leur capacité
d'agir parce que le code de l'urbanisme
est plus complexe parce que leur finan
leurs finances sont en train de de
disparaître être parce que ils sont à la
sole de des subventions décidées par
l'État et n'ont plus d'autonomie
financière parce que les interc ont pris
des compétences y compris des
compétences de proximité qui les empêche
de prendre cette somme de décisions du
quotidien qui font deux en réalité pour
leur constioyen un bon maire qui tient
ses engagements donc la principale
souffrance que moi j'ai ressenti c'est
celle-ci et du coup la population et
bien est en attente vis-à-vis de son
maère et reproche presque au maire de ne
pas faire ce pourquoi il a été élu c'est
de là que vient la difficulté majeure
voilà Jard Larché a pour habitude de
dire pierreousouia que et bien ce sont
les élus qui sont àortter de BAFF Jard
Larché qui a aussi dit dès qu'il a été
réélu pas encore à la tête du Sénat mais
sénateur des Yvelines que le Sénat
devait être un contrepouvoir
indispensable à la démocratie vous qui
êtes dans l'opposition est-ce que vous
adhérez à cette définition du Sénat
totalement et je pense qu'on pourrait
aller encore beaucoup plus loin le Sénat
a montré avec des commissions de enquête
notamment sur celle qui portait sur
mainse qui a été qui a été présidé par
ma collègue Eliana Assassi que nous
avions une une forme de de pouvoir qui
était tout à ESS seconde juste parce que
l'on voit le président du groupe
socialiste qui vient d'être réélu
Patrick canner qui vient de voter il est
également candidat au plateau je vous en
PR voilà je vous en prie et donc on a on
a un rôle tout à fait important pour
essayer de de mesurer l'impact et les
conséquences des mesures de l'État dans
les territoires hein et je crois que sur
ce point il y a un accord transpartisan
pour considérer que le Sénat devrait
aller encore plus sur le terrain pour
mesurer clairement vraiment au contact
des populations comment les législations
que nous votons ou que nous votons pas
en ce qui me concerne sont appliqué ou
pas appliqués c'est tout à fait
essentiel est-ce que Emmanuel Capu vous
êtes parfaitement d'accord avec cette
définition du Sénat comme contrepouvoir
vous qui dans votre groupe avez une
jambe dans la majoré sénatoriale une
jambe dans la majorité présidentielle
alors je sais pas si c'est pour cette
raison là mais c'est vrai que du coup la
notion de contrepouvoir je la comprends
très bien je vois ce qu'elle veut dire
je l'apprécie pas beaucoup
personnellement j'utilise plutôt le
terme de stabilisateur qui me paraît
correspond davantage à notre rôle j'aime
pas le côté contre en fait parce que
être contre ça donnerait l'impression
qu'on est contre le pouvoir
systématiquement pardon Gérard Larcher
le Président Monsieur l'actuel président
du Sénat qui sans doute va être réélu à
au plateau he pas de faux suspense qui
est en train également de voter oui
Emmanuel Capu donc vous n'adhérez pas
dis la notion contou je comprends la
notion je pense qu'elle est pas tout à
fait exacte c'estàdire je pense qu'on
est plus un stabilisateur et on l'a bien
senti ces dernières années on voit que
quand à l'Assemblée national ça se passe
pas tout à fait comme il faut il y a un
deuxième flotteur de dans notre
démocratie c'est le Sénat et donc on
stabilise les institutions on apporte ce
ce ce ce calme cette sérénité dans les
débats qui n'existe pas alors que le
terme de contrepouvoir pourrait donner
l'impression qu'on est contre le pouvoir
systématiquement et je crois pas que ça
soit le cas en tous les cas c'est pas la
vision que j'ai je crois qu'elle est
largement partagée par beaucoup on n'est
pas contre le pouvoir par principe et
encore moins depuis effectivement le
renouvellement de l'Assemblée nationale
de 2022 Sophie prima on a vu aussi le
gouvernement qui tentait de s'appuyer de
plus en plus sur le Sénat on l'a vu bien
sûr l'exemple canonique c'est la réforme
des retraites donc contre pouvoir mais
contre pouvoir qui peut aussi être dans
la construction voir plus avec le
gouvernement fait la phrase exacte du
président Larcher c'est de dire qu'on n
pas un antiouvoir mais un contrepouvoir
pour aller dans le sens de de mon
collègue donc c'est pas évidemment
contre mais c'est un contrepouvoir qui
permet justement de stabiliser cette
démocratie elle a été voulue comme ça
l'institution la création de
l'institution à la 5e République a été
voulu comme ça il suffit de reprendre
les discours de baayux du général de
Gaulle pour comprendre l'idée qui était
celle du scénna mais elle s'exprime
j'allais dire pour la première fois dans
la 5e République aussi puissamment
probablement en ce moment et l'idée
justement de ce Sénat c'est de faire en
sorte qu'une chambre une des deux
chambres du Parlement puisse faire
avancer la démocratie même si la chambre
de
l'impétuosité et des humeurs du peuple
qu'est l'Assemblée nationale a des
difficultés à trouver une majorité donc
vraiment le Sénat joue pleinement son
rôle constitutionnel et institutionnel
pendant cette période qui est le rôle de
de continuité de l'État et de continuité
de gouvernance de l'État c'est pour ça
que les textes arrivent effectivement
sou v maintenant en première lecture au
Sénat et qu'un certain nombre de
propositions de loi vont servir de base
à la législation Sophie prima pierre
rousouia je vais vous lâcher car on me
dit qu'on en est à la lettre M je
voudrais pas vous empêcher quand même de
voter Emmanuel cap je vous garde parce
que vous avez déjà voté et tout de suite
on va rejoindre mon collègue Quentin cm
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat vous êtes avec
le président du groupe socialiste qui
vient d'être réélu Patrick canner
bonjour Patrick canner effectivement
vous venez d'être réélu la semaine
dernière mardi président de votre groupe
politique voilà dans un duel qui vous
opposez à ériic kerouche un mot sur ce
qui se joue aujourd'hui vous êtes
candidat à l'élection de président mais
c'est une candidature plutôt symbolique
on est d'accord Gérard Larchet devrait
être réélu pour la 5e fois au poste de
de président du Sénat qu'est-ce que ça
vous inspire candidature candidature
symbolique mais aussi une candidature de
conviction je dire je suis un homme de
gauche Gérard Larché est un homme de
droite et quel que soit le respect qu'on
porte à la personne du président du
Sénat nous combattons régulièrement au
sein du Sénat mais avec il est vrai un
enjeu qui aujourd'hui est très très
circonscrit chacun sait que gerér Larché
sera ce soir à nouveau président du
Sénat vous disiez gauche droite ça ça
rappelle une époque avant 2017 on nous
avait promis qu'avec l'ancien monde ces
clivages allaient être effacés est-ce
que comme on a pu lire dans la presse
c'est une revanche pour l'ancien monde
cette élection de Gal Larché ce soir
savez moi je n'ai jamais cru à l'ancien
monde et au nouveau monde j'ai toujours
cru à une forme d'aventure individuelle
qui est incarnée aujourd'hui par
Emmanuel Macron voilà qu'est-ce que sera
la macronie dans 3 ans quand tout cela
va se déchirer pour la succession du
président de de la République moi je
crois oui au clivage gauche- droite
c'est un élément qui permet la
respiration démocratique on l'a vu dans
la 5e République et qui surtout est je
crois pour moi l'antidote à tous les
populismes donc le Sénat incarne cela
même si je regrette l'arrivée de trois
sénateurs er Ren qui vont faire leur
place je n'en doute pas un seul instant
attention danger pour notre démocratie
et quel doit être le positionnement de
l'institution face à l'exécutif on avait
vu le retentissement des commissions
d'enquête encore l'année dernière avec
celle sur le le fond Mariane quelle est
l'exigence que doit porter le Sénat en
2023 ce rôle de contrôle il faudra le
continuer parce que c'est un élément de
contre-pouvoir contrôle contre pouvoir
vis-à-vis d'un exécutif omnipotent et et
personnalisé de manière très directe par
le Président de la République lui-même
mais nous devons aussi être dans une
logique de proposition en tout cas pour
ce qui concerne les groupes de gauche
qui sont maintenant installés qui ont un
petit peu augmenté dans le qui ont
augmenté leur place dans le Sénat
combien de postes vous pour les
socialistes en plus nous sommes à 64
nous sommes étal mais bon vous savez la
vie continue comme dirait l'autre mais
nos amis Verts ont progressé nos amis
communistes ont progressé tout ceci dans
un accord global un accord qui n'est pas
un accord de nupes mais un accord d'une
gauche peut-être plus classique mais
tout aussi efficace un mot sur votre
famille politique puis qu'on disait
mardi dernier vous avez été réélu
président de votre groupe politique on a
vu ce matin la réélection de Claude
Rênal à la candidature pour la
présidence de la commission des finances
du Sénat mais il va y avoir un
renouvellement pour les autres postes
clés vous nous le dites à ce micro oui
nous avons marieette Carlotti qui va
succéder à Jean-Pierre Sueur à la
questure nous avons un des trois postes
vous le savez et nous aurons comme
vice-présidente Sylvie Robert donc
sénatrice dil Villen nous avons voulu
absolument au travers de de Carlotti à
travers de Sylvie Robert créer la parité
sur les quatre postes principaux qui
sont à la portée du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain et encore une
dernière question si vous me le
permettez mais on l'a vu vous avvez un
candidat face à vous Éric kerouche qui
est peut-être davantage et bien proche
d'Olivier fort aussi peut-être plus
favorable à ces accords sur laanupe
comment est-ce que vous allez conserver
voilà cette homogénéité du groupe
socialiste quand on voit qu'il y a des
différentes approches sur la stratégie
adoptée à gauche moi je suis socialiste
euh je n'ai pas changé de cremmerie
permettez-moi l'expression et je suis le
patron entre guillemets comme l'on dit
même si je n'aime pas le terme de
l'ensemble des socialistes de de ce
groupe et c'est je crois que c'est ça
qui est le le plus important vous savez
les congrès passent le groupe socialiste
reste très bien et bien on verra comment
et bien cette rentrée se passe aussi
pour votre formation politique Patrick
canner merci pour cette réaction à notre
micro merci à vous merci merci beaucoup
Quentin est tant dit que JAAC également
Yan chanrel bonjour sénateur socialiste
des Français de l'étranger alors voilà
le groupe socialiste demeure mal malgré
les les les différentes motions malgré
le fait qu'il y a pu avoir voilà
l'opposition qu'on a vu for entre Éric
kirouche et Patrick canner ça va c'est
c'est derrière vous oui c'est derrière
nous après nous vous savez on est un
groupe d'opposition ici dans cette
chambre et on va faire notre travail
d'opposition qui propose aussi hein de
proposition par rapport à un projet qui
est très différent de celui de la droite
et c'est ça que qu'on a à cœur les
socialistes peuvent avoir des fois des
des petites histoires de famille mais il
y a quand même l'essentiel qui nous
rassemble heureusement et on trouvera
lors de la session qui s'ouvre pour être
intransigeent des des combattants
féroces aussi de la politique du
gouvernement qui est soutenu en grande
partie par par cet hémicycle par le
Sénat et donc vous pouvez être sûr qu'en
tout cas on sera des des parlementaires
de combat en tout cas vous avez les yeux
braqués sur le projet de loi immigration
déjà oui absolument puisque ça c'est
pour nous vraiment on va dire
l'opposition frontale qu'on aura sur ce
projet là parce qu'on a de nombreux
désaccords c'est un projet de loi
immigration déjà qui n'est pas très
utile je pense c'est vraiment très
clientéliste électoraliste par rapport à
l'extrême droite c'est des c'est c'est
des appuis appuyés à l'extrême droite je
pense que c'est un texte de division
même pour le pays qui est vraiment nocif
je pense qu'il faut qu'à un moment donné
qu'on arrête de parler de de ce sujet
qui est pour le coup je pense un non
sujet quand on regarde réellement les
chiffres dans le détail ça n'est pas un
sujet de préoccupation le sujet de
préoccupation de nos compatriotes et des
élus qu'on est allé voir c'est pouvoir
d'achat désertification médicale
l'éducation ça c'est des sujets au cœur
des préoccupations quotidien de nos
compatriotes et c'est sur ça qu'on nous
devons intervenir et apporter des
réponses c'est pas sur le sujet de
l'immigration ou qui va donner lieu à
des débats à mon avis qui est pas à
l'honneur de notre pays Emmanuel Capu
c'est un non sujet d'immigration nous
dit Yan chantral vous êtes d'accord avec
non je suis pas d'accord c'est pas
forcément le sujet que les élus abordent
en premier c'est vrai surtout dans une
campagne sénatoriale mais faut pas non
plus euh faire l'autruche et ne pas voir
que pour le pays c'est un vrai sujet et
que si on ne fait rien dans 3 ans il y a
un risque très fort que ceux qui en
parlent tout le temps et qui font leur
choug gras de de ce sujet arrivent au
pouvoir donc il faut pas faire
l'autruche
TR de façon transpartisane je le crois
parce qu'il y a quand même un sujet on
le voit tous les jours en regardant la
télévision
c'est réfugiés qui arrivent
quotidiennement sur nos sur nos côte et
on voit bien que les Français on on
souhaite qu'on trouve des solutions
rapides efficac
pour améliorer la situation qui n'est
pas pérenne il faut pas faire l'autruche
sur l'immigration non mais par contre il
y a je suis d'accord sur le fait faut
pas faire l'autruche par exemple c'est
concernant la régularisation des des
sans papiers qui travaillent
effectivement faut pas faire l'autruche
faut les régulariser ça va être grand le
grand sujet de débat jeis d'accord ça
parimmigration par que si vous voulez
faire la course à l'échalotte de
l'extrême droite ça ne sera jamais
suffisant parce que ces gens-là veulent
quoi ils veulent zéro immigration donc
aller dans ce sens là nous ne sortirons
jamais gagnant c'est imp puissant fond
vers les abîmes de l'intolérance de la
haine et par contre oui réglons les
problèmes de personnes qui travaillent
ici en France qu' on besoin justement
c'est pas c'est c'est ça réellement
finalement être utile c'est de permettre
aux personnes qui travaillent qui sont
là depuis un certain nombre d'années de
pouvoir être régularisé et dans quel
quel qu'il soit moi je suis pas pour les
métiers en tention c'est pour t les
travailleurs parce qu'il y a pas des
travailleurs qui valent plus que
d'autres c'est tout le monde on vous
sent au taquet en tout cas pour ce
premier t qui n'arrive que le 6 novembre
je le précise he tout de même dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat un mot parce que on
va quand même revenir he sur et le Sénat
et cette journée d'élection du président
du Sénat Emmanuel Capu votre groupe s'en
sort plutôt bien on peut compter sur
trois quatre sénateurs supplémentaires
mais qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire que
les indépendants s'en sortent plutôt
bien mais que ce soit toujours aussi
compliqué pour Renaissance il a quand
même aussi une une résistance
du Sénat à la macronie aujourd'hui pas
tant au niveau du chiffre mais parce
qu'il y a eu certaines défaites
symboliques notamment bien sûr Sonia
baques qui a dû démissionner de son
poste de secrétaire d'État puisqu'elle
avait perdu aux élections sénatoriales
alors je vais pas les chiffres de moi je
vois à peu près à combien les
indépendants vont terminer je j'ai pas
les chiffres de renaissance donc je ne
sais pas oui ça serait relativement
stable voire
même il ont finalement siéger c'est
jamais facile d'ê le groupe de de la
majorité président enfin la majorité
présidentielle en espèce au Sénat mais
même à l'Assemblée nationale quand vous
êtes au pouvoir c'est pas facile c'est
vrai que c'est d'autant plus remarquable
du coup le score que font les
indépendants puisque vous savez chez les
indépendants il y en a la moitié qui
sont à horizon puis les autres qui sont
sans étiquette ça veut dire que pour
nous effectivement on est je le crois
dans un courant qui est extrêmement
porteur à l'heure
actuelle avec les indépendants vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure ni dans
l'opposition systématique ni dans le
suivisme systématique on essaie d'être
raisonnable de prendre des positions qui
sont objectives sur l'ensemble des
sujets et on le voit on sort renforcé de
cette élection et on a bah comme vous le
voyez avec des gens comme moi qui sont à
horizon qui ont donc un pied dans la
majorité présidentielle notamment avec
les ministrre que nous avons comme
Christophe Béchu et puis à côté nous
travaillons main dans la main également
avec la majorité sénatoriale et je crois
que tout à l'heure enfin en ce moment
pardon
euh les les votes sont indépendants et
sont totalement libres dans mon groupe
je pense que la totalité des collègues
vont voter pour le président Larcher
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que la
majorité est en train de un petit peu
glisser euh au centre on a vu une légère
érosion chez LR peut-être que ça monte
un petit peu chez vous ça peut changer
un petit peu aussi la façon de de
discuter des textes de de construire les
majorités oui j'espère en tous les cas
il est clair que le le le le le Sénat se
recentre très clairement euh et
que la droite la plus dure ne me paraît
pas être en ce moment euh la droite qui
réponde aux difficultés de la population
la Line retaillot vous voulez dire je
dirais la ligne siti la ligne la ligne
des dirigeants actuels de LR au Sénat on
est beaucoup plus modéré j'ai inclu
Bruno retaillot également allez tout de
suite on va refaire un tour salale des
conférences on va rejoindre Quentin
Quentin calm qui se trouve avec le
président du groupe RDP le président du
groupe des sénateur Renaissance c'est
François patria bonjour François patria
un mot sur ce qui se joue en ce moment
dans les hémicycle assez peu de suspense
on peut le dire vous vous avez pas vous
voulu présenter un candidat vous la
majorité présidentielle j'ai pensé que
représentant un groupe modéré certes
important certes travailleur mais qui ne
pèent pas dans le dans le dans
l'élection finale aujourd'hui nous
n'allons pas voter contre les opposants
contre les opposants euh systématiques
au gouvernement c'est-à-dire les voix
aujourd'hui de gauche et d'extrême
gauche hein qui s'oppos ici franchement
au gouvernement et qui d'être dans
l'opposition nous n'avions pas non plus
nous à Ti de candidat donc ne pouvons
pas non plus voter pour l'opposition qui
est représenté aujourd'hui par les les
républicains au SIAT qui disent nous
sommes l'opposition avons préféré dans
un signe je crois plutôt allez
d'apaisement de concordance de nous
abstenir de façon à ne pas créer de
l'ambiguité dans ce scrutin Gérard
Larché qui devrait être réélu au poste
de président du Sénat c'est sa 5e
élection à ce poste qu'est-ce qu'il
symbolise qu'est-ce qu'il représente à
vos yeux général archer un opposant
politique à Emmanuel Macron ou autre
chose il se dit défini lui-même comme
étant un opposant constructif et je
pense que il a sa place dans cet
hémicycle parce qu'il est élu depuis 82
je vous rappelle que nous sommes
confrères tous les deux que nous avons
fait la même préparation à l'école
vétérinaire nousous connaissons depuis
longtemps nous avons les mêmes pratiques
sportives donc je peux dire aujourd'hui
qu'on se connaît bien donc j'ai plutôt à
l'égard de Gérard Larcher sentiment de
d'amitié et cetera il y a pas de deux
amateurs de la chasse c'est bien ça en
plus en plus bien mais Gérard larch
aujourd'hui ce qu'il pr c'est qu'il il
sait aujourd'hui traiter sa majorité il
a su s'imposer dans son propre camp il
l'a fait avec beaucoup de à la fois
d'élégance et de fermeté donc il a il a
un talent de manager de de traiter les
hommes de distribuer ici les postes
qu'il souhaite dans l'INT du Sénat il
fait l'unanimité dans la majorité
sénatoriale et même un peu sur le centre
à côté on verra que ces voix déborderont
largement les voix des républicains et
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
positionnement politique du Sénat comme
institution ça a été souvent un poil à
gratter de la macronamment à travers des
commissions d'enquête qui ont été
organisées régulièr depuis 2017
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous de ce
positionnement politique de de
l'institution je pense que depuis le
début du quinquena le positionnement a
évolué la preuve on est nous sommes
arrivés à beaucoup de commissions mix
paritair positive ça veut dire ça va
conclure les travaux parlementaires
autour d'un texte alors ça veut dire que
beaucoup de textes sont passés parce que
le Sénat a eu évoluer a su trouver a su
trouver des des Mo de compromission on
va aller écouter je vous interromps un
instant puisqu'on va écouter le
président tin excusez-moi la séance est
suspendue évidemment pendant ces
opérations de dépouillement
dépouillement tout le mond
aé oui voilà tandis que vous le
comprenez et bien les sénateurs ont
terminé de voter place donc au
dépouillement qui va prendre quand même
quelques minutes dépouillement on le
disait où normalement il ne devrait pas
y avoir de très grandes surprises voilà
on voit les urnes qui sont en train
d'arriver salale des conférences
elles vont être dépouillées voilà sur
cette table près de la cheminée de la
salle des conférence hein voilà les 348
sénateurs ont voté pour leurs candidats
je vous rappelle qu'il y a donc quatre
candidats au plateau Cécile cuquierman
pour le groupe communiste Patrick canner
pour le groupe socialiste également
Guillaume Gontard pour le groupe
écologiste et bien sûr le candidat de la
majorité de la droite et du centre
Gérard Larché qui est donc candidat pour
un 5e mandat de président du Sénat et
vous voyez donc voilà les huissiers qui
sont en train de sortir toutes les les
enveloppes en cette salle des
conférences euh voilà Yann Chantrel
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire cette
longévité de Gérard Larché car bon on va
pas jouer le le suspense outre mesure a
priori il devrait être réélu c'est quoi
le secret de Gérard alarcher pour pour
durer à ce point-là au sein de de
l'hémicycle du Sénat on sait qu'il est
aussi apprécié par par les oppositions
oui il va finir par devenir une
institution à lui tout seul représenter
le Sénat alors après faut voir que le
Sénat déjà un mode de de sélection très
différente de scrutin que l'Assemblée
nationale oui ce qui ce qui peut
expliquer aussi ce ce type de longévité
moi personnellement je suis plutôt pour
le non cumule dans le temps donc je vais
pas défendre le le fait d'être 40 ans en
poste je pense qu'au contraire notre
pays et d'ailleurs il y a eu une part de
renouvellement au niveau de des
élections qui viennent de se dérouler la
preuve pour regarder ceux qui sont au
bureau d'âge il y en a CIN qui sont de
gauche sourc donc ça donne quand même
aussi que le ouvellement est aussi du
côté de la gauche à un moment donné et
que il y a une forme de renouvellement
donc moi je salue bien sûr la longévité
du président du Sénat mais je pense
qu'il faut qu'on aille plus loin et on
devrait nous-même peut-être donner
l'exemple dans des non cumules d'entemps
il y a le non cumu déjà qui est très une
très bonne chose qui est une avancé même
s'il y a des forces qui vont à
l'encontre de ça vous ouvrez le débat
sur cumule dans le temps pour ou je
pense qu'un moment donné il faud bah pas
pour Gérard Larcher spécifiquement pour
l'ensemble des parlementaires je pense
que c'est quelque chose vers lequel il
faut aller c'est-à-dire que être élu
c'est un passage ça n'est pas un métier
en soi on représente nos concitoyens et
concitoyennes pendant un lapse de temps
et il faut permettre à d'autres de le
faire c'est ça le non renouvellement
dans le temps et je pense que ça c'est
quelque chose qui est sain dans des
plein de démocratie vous avez un
renouvellement assez régulier de de nos
représentants et je pense que ça serait
à l'honneur de notre institution et du
débat politique on mettra dans le débat
on fera même des propositions dans ce
sens de permettre ça tandis que
j'accueille sur ce plateau xaviacovelli
bonjour sénateur renaissance des hautes
scènes vous venez d'être réélu c'était
pas gagné pour de de votre côté toutes
mes félicitations vous êtes avec quel
sentiment vous retrouvver déjà public
pens public pensa que c'était pas à
quiis mais enfin moi je pensais depuis
le début que c'était quelque chose qui
était faisable non pas gagnable mais en
tout cas que le travail qui a été fait
pendant 6 ans sur le terrain auprès des
élus locaux allait se concrétiser donc
moi je j'avais aucun doute contrairement
à certaines presses bien intentionné à
notre égard depuis quelques mois ah
c'était pas forc
la
presseav jus jusqu'à encore dimanche
vous pensiez que jusqu'à même et encore
quelques jours vous pensiez que nous
étions un groupe à peine 16 ou 17 on va
finir un groupe à 22 pour un groupe qui
était à 24 avec quatre quatre sortants
qui ne se représentaient pas donc c'est
plutôt effectivement une bonne nouvelle
pour notre ou vous estimez que vous
résistez plutôt même puisque vous vous
vous progressez en chiffre mais je le
disais tout à l'heure il y a eu un
certain nombre de de défaites
symboliques notamment celle de la secr
d'État secrétaire d'État Sonia BES ça
reste une chambre qui qui qui qui
résiste à la à la macronie c'est quand
même pas un scrutin qui vous est
favorable vous savez moi je je vois le
le résultat aujourd'hui la majorité
présidentielle dans son ensemble elle
progresse avec les indépendants avec à
majorité horizon avec les modem qui sont
à l'Union centriste avec un certain
nombre de centristes qui sont également
à l'Union centriste et avec le groupe
RDP qui est à majorité Renaissance donc
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui qu'il y a
une progression en nombre de sénateurs
et de sénatrices de la majorité
présidentielle celle qui soutient
l'action du gouvernement et du président
de la République il y a une progression
effectivement des forces de gauche et
elle est notable on l'a vu avec la
progression notamment des des petits
groupe écologiste et et communiste et il
y a un tassement de de du groupe à
majorité LR qui perd une dizaine qui per
une dizaine 10 ou 13 je crois mais donc
voilà donc on voit un rééquilibrage mais
qui est en fait la la concrétisation des
élections municipal de 2020 en fait donc
il y avait pas de grande surprise on
savait très bien que c'était un scrutin
qui était difficile pour la majorité
prés présidentielle et pour autant on a
réussi à convaincre dans nos
territoirees au-delà de ceux qui étaient
étiqueté majorité présidentielle il y a
donc une une forme de stabilité mais
vous le dites il y a quand même une
évolution de cette chambre que l'on
observe tandis que nous accueillons la
sénatrice les républicains des bouches
du rô Valérie Boyer bonjour un peu
l'auberge espagnool ce plateau Valérie
Boyer pleine élection c'est normal voilà
un mot sur voilà l'état dans lequel sort
cette Chambre haute du scrutin du 24
septembre vous avz yakovelli observa
qu'il y a un tassement du côté de LR
avec la perte d'une dizaine de sièges
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire il y a
néanmoins la majorité qui reste à à
droite et au centre vous allez vers 135
136 sénateur au lieu de 145 avant le
renouvellement c'est cette élection là
de de-mandat municipal est une élection
qui est le reflet des élections
municipales donc j'imagine que mes
collègues ont tous dû dire ça c'est la
prochaine élection qui sera probablement
différente ou pas hein sauf si les
élections municipales sont identiques
moi ce que j'observe c'est que nous
restons majoritaires avec la droite et
le centre et que ben j'espère qu'on va
continuer le le bon travail qui a été
fait au Sénat parce que je crois que
aujourd'hui plus personne ne conteste le
rôle très important du Sénat et et son
apport dans la
démocratie parlementaire mais dans la
démocratie française qui est extrêmement
important c'est vrai que c'est la
chambre de du temps long du travail
approfondi et travail de contrôle aussi
trava de contrôle effectivement j'all
j'allais y venir effectivement et un
travail de
contrôle qui se
fait je pense qu' a vraiment
marqué marqué ces dernières années qui a
permis aussi sans doute de redorer
l'image du Sénat
qui oui enfin je rappelle quand même
même que les périodes où la France n'a
pas eu de Sénat n'étaiit pas les
périodes les plus heureuses ni les plus
démocratiques c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire hein donc effectivement euh
pratiquement toutes les démocraties ont
une double chambre et on voit bien tout
le rôle de la nôtre aujourd'hui et puis
en plus avec cette chambre des
territoires don dont le rôle a été
accentué et qui est de plus en plus
nécessaire moi je quand même ces
dernières années ont été marquées par
balance tomonè des choses qui sont très
très difficiles et très douloureuse pour
euh pour pour les maires et pour les
pour les territoires le non cumule des
mandats aussi a coupé le le Parlement de
de je pense que qui est une grave erreur
et j'espère que on y reviendra un jour
mais à couper le Parlement de de de la
base aussi certain et et grâce au Sénat
ben je pense que cet encrage territorial
là peut être confirmé allez tout de
suite on va rejoindre Quentin Quentin
quel mec qui se trouve dans la salle des
conférences du Sénat car Quentin nous
sommes en plein dépouille de ce scrutin
plein de suspense ah oui non pas
forcément beaucoup de de suspense
effectivement mais on voulait quand même
vous montrer comment ça se passe sur ces
images de Jean-Baptiste Gaillot regardez
il y a trois tables qui ont été
installées en salle des conférences à
ces table il y a à la fois des
administrateurs du Sénat ainsi que des
membres du bureau d'âge les plus jeunes
sénateurs pour l'occasion qui participe
au dépouillement le tout sous la
surveillance d'huissier vous les voyez
avec effectivement et bien leur
médailles sur leur veston donc ça c'est
le dépouillement qui a lieu en plein
cœur la salle des conférences on voit
comme ça Rémy Cardon l'élu de la somme
qui est concentré avec Mathilde Olivier
qui est également la benjamine du Sénat
juste ici à cette table ça se passe donc
au milieu de la salle des conférences et
derrière et bien on voit les sénateurs
qui sont sortis de l'émicycle puisque
tout le monde a terminé de voter et
qu'on attend maintenant le résultat du
dépouillement et donc les sénateurs qui
conversent qui discutent en attendant le
résultat qui devrait être proclamé dans
les prochaines minutes Tam avec
effectivement assez peu de suspense on
peut le dire merci merci beaucoup
Quentin voilà ambiance de rentrer des
classes dans l'hémicycle mais aussi dans
la salle des conférences Xavier
yacovelli on parlait à l'instant un
petit peu de peut-être aussi de l'état
d'esprit des élus locaux vous qui sortez
aussi d'une de campagne qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire de ce que vous
avez ressenti sur le terrain de l'état
d'esprit de ces élus est-ce que vous
avez senti bien ce malaise dont on
parlait parfois c'est ces élus qui on
ont un peu marre qui ont pas envie de de
rempiler qui ressent un malaise moi j'ai
ressenti une grande fatigue on est à mi
mandat sur ces élections municipales sur
son mandat municipal j'ai trouvé une
grande fatigue effectivement des élus
locaux qui qui sont vraiment les
premiers remparts de la République en
fait les premiers acteurs en tout cas de
de notre démocratie local et et qui sont
épuisés par effectivement beaucoup de
normes beaucoup de règles et petit à
petit en fait gouvernement après
gouvernement et là je pense que quelle
que soit la couleur politique des
gouvernements qui se sont succédés
depuis 15 ans on est tous respons able
on a petit à petit enlevé des des
prérogatives aux élus locaux et aux
maires en particulier et je pense que
c'est vraiment ça ils ont besoin de de
retrouver ce lien direct avec les
citoyens et donc je pense qu'il faut
renforcer le lien du le le le pouvoir de
décision pardon des maires et des élus
locaux avec en enlevant effectivement
des strates qui parfois enlèvent la
décision de l'élu local au détriment de
de d'autres d'autres strates et puis il
faut renforcer créer ce statut de l'élu
local pour protéger aussi nos élus euh
je pense que quand on parlait qu'il y
avait 85 % des élus locaux qui ne sont
pas indemnisés dans notre pays je pense
qu'il faut poser ce ce ce débat sur la
table je pense qu'il faut assumer
clairement que quand on est élu local on
le fait pour l'intérêt général on le
fait pas pour les indemnités mais que
les indemnités permettent aussi
d'assurer un certain un certain mandat
pour l'intérêt des autres et donc il
faut avoir ce débat effectivement qu'on
qu'on doit assumer dans l'opinion
publique est-ce que ça va dans dans ce
sens Emmanuel Capu quand on voit que par
exemple il y a une semaine quand
Emmanuel Macron s'est exprimé le soir
des élections sénatoriales et bien il a
notamment rejeté la faute de la hausse
de des impôts fonciers sur les élus
locaux et sur les maires alorsà c'est
peut-être pas le bon exemple mais je
crois Christ béch a écrit une tribune
très intéressante là-dessus dans le
figarou il rappelle qu'en fait
euh c'était sans doute quelques maires
qui étaient visés notamment je pense à
des maires qui ont augmenté de 50 % euh
la taxe foncière notamment ou notamment
à Paris il y a quelques grand-maes comme
ça qui ont je pense un tout petit peu
abusé et parce que pour le reste il est
évident qu'en tant que sénateur et en
tant que élu local je défends
particulièrement l'autonomie financière
des collectivités territoriales et que
au contraire j'ai constaté sur le
terrain une très
grande sagesse des élus locaux des
maires en particulier qui gèent leur
budget comme ils le peuvent àqu
équilibre ça parce qu'il c'est
obligatoire et qui n'ont plus que la
taxe foncière comme levier donc
évidemment quand il faut l'augmenter ils
l'augmente ils n'ont plus que ça et
quand il faut la quand ils peuvent la
baisser mais c'est de plus en plus rare
il il la baisse moi ce que je souhaite
ce qu'on est beaucoup avoir demandé dans
cette campagne c'est une vraie autonomie
c'est le maintien des dotations parce
que je crois qu'il faudrait je crois que
c'est je crois que c'est mentir aux
Français que de dire qu'on pourrait les
augmenter aujourd'hui compte tenu de
notre dette et il faut aussi sécuriser
la dette de l'État maintenir les
dotations à un niveau correct qui
permettent aux élus locaux d'agir
correctement et surtout avoir plus de
prévisibilité de visibilité ne pas
arrêter enfin plutôt arrêter d'imposer
au Mair des choses sur laquelle ils
n'ont pas la main et en revanche pour
laquelle ils doivent payer Yan Chantrel
he sans rentrer dans un forcément dans
un débat de de fiscalité on est aussi
dans un contexte effectivement on a pu
voir quand même certaines crispations
entre le gouvernement et les élus locaux
ces dernières semaines ces dernières
années ça date pas d'Emmanuel Macron he
des je veux dire des des crispations
entre le gouvernement et les élus locaux
il y en avait eu sous François Hollande
il y en avait eu sous Nicolas sarcosi
bah après les crispations elles sont pas
que vis-à-vis de des élus locaux elles
sont vis-à-vis des Français parce que il
y a une pratique du pouvoir très
verticale de la part du du président de
la République elle est verticale
vis-à-vis des Français mais elle est
verticale aussi vis-à-vis des élus
locaux et contrairement à ce qu'on dit
on a assisté à une sorte de
recentralisation à travers la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation vous
dites être attaché l'autonomie bah ça ça
n'est pas un acte d'autonomie c'est
plutôt tout le contraire euh et d'où le
fait que certaines municipalités
essayent de trouver de l'argent ailleurs
avec d'autres d'autres moyens donc faut
pas les accuser eux c'est plutôt la
centralisation qu'il faut qu'il faut
accuser parce que la compensation on a
eu lieu mais quand vous voyez la la
l'inflation qui
galop euh il faut les compenser beaucoup
plus que la manière dont elle été
compensée au début parce que ça augmente
sans cesse et puis l'autonomie faisait
qu'on pouvait l'augmenter aussi donc là
clairement je pense que les élus ne sont
pas contents par rapport à ça parce que
c'est des pouvoirs qui le seé ils ont
beaucoup de difficultés parce qu'ils ont
effectivement une charge très
importantes ils ne sont pas suffisamment
reconnus d'où le fait qu'il faut
défendre un véritable statut de l'élu
tout à l'heure je parlais de non cumule
dans le temps mais tout ça doit aller
aussi avec des vrais statuts pour qu'on
puisse se réinsérer aussi dans la
société que ça soit une passerelle ce
soit pas un métier de faire de la
politique et ceux qui n'en font pas un
métier parce qu'ils peuvent pas s'en
permettre c'est justement nos élus
locaux parce que il y a pas suffisamment
de garantie ou d'aide parce que
contrairement c'est c'est c'est très
difficile d'être un élu local il y en a
plus beaucoup qui veulent le faire
justement on peut avoir potentiellement
une crise de vocation exactement ce sont
parce qu'il on revenus voilà il faut que
ça puisse être aussi à l'image de la
société sociologiquement donc ça c'est
important aussi qu'on y travaille et je
pense que sur l'ensemble des bans de
cette assemblée je pense qu'on a la
possibilité aussi de trouver des accords
pour aller dans ce sens-là et renforcer
justement les pouvoirs et aussi les
conditions d'exercice du mandat pour les
élus locaux bon c'est un sujet sur
lequel il peut y avoir des consensus qui
peuvent euh naître euh Valérie Boyer un
mot sur le positionnement du Sénat
comment est-ce que vous le voyez euh
avec ce nouveau Sénat euh on est passé
d'une opposition qui était très claire
sur le premier mandat d'Emmanuel Macron
à parfois des des partenariats qui ont
pu se nouer euh sur euh la la dernière
année notamment bien sûr sur les
retraites mais mais pas seulement
comment doit se positionner pour vous le
Sénat vis-à-vis du gouvernement
aujourd'hui euh sur les retraites je me
permet juste de vous rappeler qu'on
voulait voter notre texte
euh que c'est le gouvernement qui est
allé surition et ne pas aller sur les
Herms qui qui se sont déroulés euh bah
on verra parce que c'est vrai qu'on
attend des grands textes notamment celui
sur
l'immigration est quand même un sujet
central qui préoccupe tous les Français
euh et il s'agit pas de droite Durre ou
de droite molle ou de il s'agit de
répondre à des angoisses aujourd'hui euh
qui sont ressentis sur l' ensemble du
territoire en France et en Europe
d'ailleurs et aussi et aussi assumer
dignement quand on choisi d'accueillir
des personnes parce que c'est pour les
accueillir et les laisser sur les aires
d'autoroute ou sur les trottoirs de nos
villes je vois pas où est la dignité où
est la générosité donc cette grande
difficulté qui fait souffrir à la fois
les migrants et ceux qui les accueillent
contre leur volonté la plupart du temps
en tout cas c'est ce que disent les
sondages euh je pense qu'il va falloir
la traiter et ça passera par le Sénat
puisque le gouvernement s'était engagé à
à ce que ce texte passe d'abord par par
le Sénat l'examen en commission a déjà
eue l'examen en commission a déjà eu
lieu et on verra comment les choses vont
se dérouler mais c'est un sujet sur
lequel on peut plus procrastiner et il
est certain que le Sénat a été en tout
cas ma famille politique a été a été
vraiment très loin là-dedans puisqu'elle
a déposé le même texte au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale euh et puis ce
texte a été examiné au Sénat après mout
rapport voilà un sujet je pense qu' va
faire la rentrée moi je voudrais juste
revenir sur le débat précédent sur sur
les élus locaux et sur la façon dont
dont ça se passe localement je pense
qu'effectivement la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation c'était un très beau
slogan électoral qui a été efficace
maintenant pour l'efficacité de notre
territoire c'est difficile parce que
aujourd'hui on a un manque
d'autonomie je pense à un sujet qui est
majeur qui est celui du logement on a un
manque d'autonomie total des maires qui
se voi imposer notamment pour le
logement social par les préfectures des
personnes sans qu'il les choisissent et
ça on n'arrive pas à avancer sur ce
sujet je pense qu'il faudrait avancer et
puis c'est faire peser sur les
propriétaires qui sont pas forcément des
gensantis une pression qui va quand même
être quelque chose de très très
difficile hein puisque suppression de la
taxe d'habitation et puis moi je pense
que c'était c'était une très mauvaise
idée parce que je crois que chacun doit
participer à la vie de la cité et la vie
de la cité ça passe aussi par là et
avoir supprimé cette cet outil des mes
alors c'est vrai que c'est compensé mais
c'est pas compenser à la hauteur de ce
que voudrait les maires à la fois ça les
ça les coupe d'une partie de leur
population mais aussi ça les rend
totalement dépendants des autres
collectivité et je pense notamment au
département et à la région avec qui ils
ont un rapport de proximité euh et aussi
de dépendance financière et je pense que
ça c'est pas très bon pour l'autonomie
des villes la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation ça a laissé des traces he
ça dat djà quelques années et cetera
mais on on sent que ça a laissé vraiment
des traces auprès des élus locaux c'est
un sujet majeur oui alors effectivement
sur la taxe la taxe d'habitation moi je
vais pas vous dire le contraire j'ai
fait campagne effectivement sur la
suppression on va dire de la taxe
foncière et de la dotation de
compensation de la taxe d'habitation
pour créer un impôt résident je pense
effectivement et je suis d'accord avec
Valérie Boyet il faut qu'il y ait ce
lien entre le citoyen et l'élu sur le la
décision donc moi en tant que citoyen
j'étais très content de la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation en tant que
parlementaire j'ai soutenu la
suppression de cette taxe d'habitation
en tant qu'élu local je me dis
effectivement qu'il fa valoir peut-être
réinventer quelque chose et ça ne peut
pas être du rafistolage par une dotation
une compensation parce que c'est là où
on perd parce que contrairement à ce que
vous dites malgré tout ça a été quand
même compensé à l'euro près avec une
dynamique malgré tout les départements
en ont profité puisqu'il y a une
dynamique avec une dose sur la sur la
TVA qui est qui est dynamique mais
globalement il faut effectivement
retrouver de l'autonomie et l'autonomie
passe par un impôt direct entre le
citoyen et la collectivité locale allez
tout de suite on va on retourne salle
des conférences on va retrouver Quentin
calma qui se trouve avec le doyen du
Sénat que nous avons écouté tout à
l'heure le sénateur Union centriste du
pcalis c'est Jean-Marie vanon lurenberg
qui est à votre micro bonjour Jean-Marie
van lorenberg et on le dit à l'heure
actuelle à l'heure où l' se parle vous
êtes le président du Sénat c'est une
fonction qui vous é choix au titre de
effectivement du fait que vous êtes le
doyen d'âge alors que le dépouillement
est toujours jour en cours dans la salle
des conférences un mot sur ce que vous
vous avez ressenti alors c'est la
deuxième fois que vous vous occupez ce
poste vous avez pu prononcer un discours
ça vous donne quoi comme sentiment
d'ouvrir la session parlementaire 2023
bah c'est toujours un honneur hein bien
sûr que de le faire même si c'est au
titre du doyen d'âge ça reste un moment
important dans une vie que de pouvoir le
faire et surtout que j'accueillais ma
fille et pour la première fois
effectivement le père et la fille vont
siéger en même temps et dans le même
groupe
au Sénat et de deux départements je
précise différents oui elle est élu dans
les hautes scènes effectivement c'est
une première sous la 5e
puisqueeffectivement votre fille madame
Floren va exactement également rentrer
au Sénat au groupe Union centriste elle
est élu sur la liste d'Hervé Marseille
vous avez un message aux jeunes
générations cell qui arrivent notamment
avec le bureau d'âge on a vu ces six
plus jeunes sénateurs qui sont parfois
sous la barre des 30 ans quel est votre
message vous sur et bien l'avenir de la
politique et l'avenir de institutions
écoutez je pense moi que l'avenir il
repose effectivement sur eux sur leurs
valeurs je pense que s'ils sont là c'est
qu'ils croient à la République qu'il
croi à la démocratie ce sont mes valeurs
moi je suis fier de les transmettre à ma
fille je suis fier de les transmettre à
tous ceux qui m'entourent avoir autour
de moi des jeunes mères des jeunes élus
qui se sont ont fait leur leur tour ont
pris leur tour bien sûr parce qu'il faut
de la persévérance je crois que ce que
je leur dirais il suffit pas d'être élu
une fois il faut être réélu et je pense
qu'il faut aussi aider les autres à
conquérir les territoires parce que
aujourd'hui les territoires sont menacés
il y a une menace populiste il y a une
menace extrémiste et moi je veux lutter
contre ça je pense que c'est là je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure dans mon discours ce
sont les élus locaux que nous
représentons qui sont l'armée de la
République du côté quotidien ils sont en
première ligne et donc c'est eux qu'il
faut effectivement privilégier dans nos
interventions dans nos dans nos lois
dans nos je dirais nos règlements d'une
façon générale il faut tenir compte
parce qu'ils se sentent aujourd'hui et
c'est la leçon de cette élection ils se
sentent un peu délaissé il nous reste
une minute d'interview si vous le voulez
bien on va aller voir votre fille
puisque vous le disiez madame Floren
bonjour vous faites votre entrée ici à
la Chambre haute du Parlement et c'est
une première que VI de rappeler votre
père jean-mar vanber c'est que c'est la
première fois sous la 5è que un père et
sa fille vont siéger dans la même
chambre du Parlement qu'est-ce que ça
vous évoque vous voilà ce cette
information bah écoutez c'est c'est
assez émouvant aujourd'hui et puis pour
moi c'est un retour dans une assemblée
que j'affectionne particulièrement j'ai
travaillé quelques années et et bon on
siège pas dans les mêmes commissions je
je sais et on n'est pas dans les mêmes
appartement mais en tout cas on est tous
les deux engagés pour notre territoire
et alors on voyit l'expérience de
Jean-Marie vanberg qu'est-ce que vous
avec vos yeux de nouvelles sénatrices
vous voulez apporter à l'institution du
Sénat bah écoutez dans mon département
je trouve que il y a une chose à
souligner c'est que trois femmes
arrivent trois sénatrices arrivent sur
les SEP dans les hautes scènes sur les
SEP sénateurs donc je trouve que bah une
côté féminin la parité qui s'exprime et
puis défendre de toute façon la
décentralisation quel que soit le
département je pense que c'est ça notre
engagement quel que soit notre
département en tout cas tous les deux et
bien merci merci pour cette interview
croisée et peut-être aussi une première
pour tous les deux d'être réunis pour
une interview sur l'antainne de Public
Sénat
s merci merci merci beaucoup Quentin
d'ailleurs Jean-Marie van lurenberg
l'avait dit dès le début de son discours
il a jamais été autant médiatisé depuis
qu'il a 4 4 ans et depuis qu'il rentre
il rerentre au Sénat en même temps que
sa fille Isabelle Floren donc qui est
nouvellement élu sénatrice des hautes
scènes je voudrais vous faire réagir à
quelque chose qu'a dit Jean-Marie van
larenberg tout à l'heure dans son
discours il a dit à l'Assemblée on tue
avec le poignard au Sénat on empoisonne
avec le sourire ça vous fait sourire ou
pas Xavi yacovelli c'est ces propos non
mais ça veut dire qu'il peut y avoir des
clivages aussi forts à au Sénat qu'
l'assemblée même si ça peut être plus
feutré oui on a on a des clivages
forcément sinon on serait tous dans la
mêmeque rest une assemblée politique qui
est représentative aussi de de la
diversité des opinions politiques de
notre pays donc oui il y a des
diversgences mais on on est plutôt
raisonnable et on arrive TR quand même
dans C'est un peu dans laadn du Sénat de
trouver des compromis et on arrive
globalement à à trouver des compromis
sur un certain nombre de textes en tout
cas on essaie de faire avancer les
textes et de bien écrire la loi on a
l'habitude de dire qu'on corrige les
excentricités de l'Assemblée nationale
mais c'est un peu ça vraiment quand vos
collègues de
l'Assemblée je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
il y a beaucoup de postures et et peu de
de travail de fond et c'est ce que moi
j'ai trouvé dans au Sénat quand je suis
arrivé il il y a 6 ans il y a ce travail
vraiment de on écrit correctement la loi
on essaie de qu'elle ne soit pas bavarde
et d'ailleurs on voit 80 % des
amendements qui sont présentés au Sénat
se retrouvent dans la loi Infiné après
les CMP ou après une deuxième lecture
donc on voit qu'il y a un vrai travail
de fond du Sénat chantrelle oui bah déjà
le fait de quand on a deux chambres
l'intérêt c'est qu'elle soit pas
identique faut qu'elle soit différente
sinon il y a peu d'intérêt d'en avoir
deux donc c'est le cas effectivement et
ça n'empêche pas en tout cas d'avoir et
j'en ai avec avec mes collègues des
oppositions très fortes sur le fond on
peut on peut se respecter humainement et
avoir des oppositions frontales sur le
fond et on en a aussi même si on arrive
quand on parle de toute façon de on en a
parlé tout à l'heure sur les élus locaux
comme vous voez il peut y avoir aussi
des choses qui dépassent l'équlibrage
politique effectivement parce que là
c'est des choses très concrète qui
concerne justement les les élus locaux
mais sur d'autres sujets par exemple
celui qui a été évoqué sur l'immigration
PE
sera dur il sera dur il sera front comme
il l'a été d'ailleurs sur les retraites
où c'était un vraivage gauchoite
finalement c'est ce qui manque peut-être
aussi à notre pays parce que Emmanuel
macronion très dangereuse de faire
croire que la gauche et la droite
c'était la même chose et de désigner
ainsi ce que disait l'extrême droite
depuis 30 ans et il disait UMPS il a
repris les mot de l'extrême droite ce
qui est totalement faux et quelque part
il en a
fait opposant il avait même dit quand il
a été élu vous verrez dans 5 ans il y
aura plus aucune raison de voter pour
l'extr ça a explosé ils ont fait plus de
40 % donc ça ça c'est ça s'il peut y
avoir un vrai clivage gauche droite
c'est c'est dans cette chambre justement
c'est au Sénat et et je pense que ça il
est utile il est nécessaire pour notre
pays parce que la passerelle pour
l'extrême droite c'est quand on dit que
les deux sont les mêmes parce que ça
n'est pas vrai d'une part et ça c'est
terriblement dangereux parce que vous
préparez le terrain potentiellement à
une seule opposition qui serait celle de
l'extrême droite et ça c'est terrible
pour notre pays et il faut briser ça et
j'espère que nous reviendrons
progressivement lors de la prochaine
élection présidentielle puisque Édouard
Philippe il y a aucun doute sur le fait
qu'il est droite lui en tout cas il s'en
est jamais caché ce qui nous permettra
peut-être si c'est lui le candidat ce
que certains espèrent parce qu'on voit
aussi le jeu de chaise musicale parce
que perd aussi des gens parce qu'il app
famille retrouver ce débat finalement
structurel de la vie politique française
on peut on peut pas laisser dire aussi
que le président a dit que la gauche et
la droite c'était la même chose non il a
en sorte effectivement depuis 2016
depuis 2017 de réunir de
réunirou et de gauche et de droite c'est
pas gauche de droite et donc
pardonnez-moi je voudra je vous ai pas
interrompu en l'occurrence faire en
sorte de réunir les bonnes énergies de
droite et de gauche ceux qui m'ont envie
de travailler pour pour l'intérêt
général et pour l'intérêt des Français
c'est ce que les Français demandaient et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils ont
balayé et le Parti socialiste et l'R et
que penseer que l'ELR ou le Parti
socialiste reviendrait dans un cvage
gauche droite comme c'était le cas avant
c'est mon tir au français parce que
personne ne veut de ça et effectivement
il y a toujours il y a toujours cet axe
central avec des gens ISS de la droite
des gens issus de la gauche avec
peut-être d'autres passerelles avec le
Parti socialiste ou avec lesr pourquoi
pas mais revenir sur un cage qui existit
avant
existejoursoteot làdus un petit souvenir
de campagne é
moi je me souviens et ce serait
intéressant que vous sortiez les
archives de voir Monsieur Ferrand à
l'époque qui sortait d'être président de
de l'Assemblée nationale et Madame
Chiapa en train de dire à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon votez pour nous parce que nous
partageons les mêmes valeur plus plus
personne franchement c'est qu même
incroable on va rejoindre Quentin qui se
trouve salle des conférences parce que
Quentin le dépouillement vient de se
terminer exactement le dépouillement est
TER terminé effectivement vous voyez
toutes les opérations de comptes des
enveloppes de décomptees aussi des votes
sont terminés les assesseurs qui
viennent effectivement de noter sur des
fiches le nombre de voix pour chacun des
quatre candidats il y a plus maintenant
qu'à proclamer ses résultats ça va se
jouer dans l'hémicycle mais voilà ils
sont en train de libérer la partie de la
salle des conférences qui était voilà
qui était occupée par le bureau de
dépouillement de l'élection du président
du Sénat avec ces six administrateurs du
Sénat ces six sénateurs les plus jeunes
du Sénat qui ont terminé de compter les
348 enveloppes et on va pouvoir avoir la
proclamation dans les prochaines minutes
al dans l'enceinte de l'émicycle TH et
vous l'avez dit ça va se passer donc
dans l'hémicycle et dans l'hémicycle on
va rejoindre tout de suite Mathias qui
se trouve dans la tribune de presse vous
avez une vision panoramique de ce qui se
passe derrière Mathias qu'est-ce qui va
se passer chez chez vous dans un instant
et ben écoutez l'hémicycle est en train
de se remplir à nouveau ça y est les
sénateurs sont de retour Gérard Larcher
va prendre place à son siège comme les
trois autres candidats vous voyez ça y
est le le bureau d'âge est également de
retour et va s'installer au plateau au
place qu'ils occupaient tout à l'heure
les résultats vont être apportés par un
huissier ils seront donc proclamés par
le président d' Jean-Marie van lurenberg
qui était tout à l'heure à votre micro
et on va ensuite donc passer au discours
du président élu si d'aventure un
candidat obtenait la majorité absolue
dès le premier tour dans le cas
contraire il y aurait un second tour qui
devrait s'organiser mais si un candidat
obtient une majorité absolue il prendra
donc la parole ici à la tribune Tam
merci merci beaucoup Mathias oui bon il
y a pas énormément de suspense Emmanuel
Capu bon on ce qu'on va regarder c'est
est-ce que Gérard Larché a fait mieux
qu'il a quelques années qui a 3 ans la
dernière fois il Ava fait 231 voix ce
qui était mieux que la fois précédente
en 2017 attendis qu'on entend que ça
sonne et pu un mot oui il y a pas un
énorme suspense ce qu'on va voir c'est
jusqu'ù va la majorité sénatoriale au
sens large c'est-à-dire en plus du
groupe LR en plus du groupe Union
centriste combien il y a de voix
supplémentaires pour voir jusqu'à
jusqu'où vont les les limites la
périphérie de la majorité sénatoriale
c'est ça l'intérêt en fait c'est ça
parce que vous avez compris qu'au-delà
du groupe l et du groupe Union
centristeard Larché est apprécié y
compris par les groupes minoritaires
allez pu on va tout de suite rejoindre
et bien l'hémicycle du Sénat où se
trouve donc
és deette sé qui
ouvre cette session parlementaire après
ce Sénat qui a été renouvelé le 24
septembre dernier on va écouter
Jean-Marie vanlerenberg qui va qui s'est
installé au niveau du
plateau mais on va on va on va l'écouter
bientôt proclamer les résultats je vous
rappelle les candidats qu'il y avait au
PL Cécile cuckerman pour le groupe
communiste Guillaume Gontard pour le
groupe écologiste Patrick canner pour le
groupe socialiste et donc Gérard Larcher
candidat de la majorité de la droite du
Centre he pas de candidat du côté de
renaissance voilà on devrait donc avoir
les résultats d'un instant à l'autre
maintenant tandis que vous le voyez
l'hémicycle est presque comble et que
Jean-Marie van lerenberg attend que les
sénateurs s'installent tous à leur place
voilà dans cet hémicycle et tandis que
l'on voit également le ministre de
relations avec le Parlement Franck
Riester qui s'installe au banc des
ministres voilà donc la dernière fois
Gérard Larcher avait été réélu pour la
4e fois avec 231 voix alors on va voir
s'il va faire mieux ou peut-être moins
bien ça sera peut-être cela qui pourra
permettre de donner la température et la
taille de la majorité sénatoriale sur ce
nouveau scrutin de 2023 ettandis que
l'on voit voilà Gérard alarché le
président du Sénat sortant qui est donc
à sa place de sénateur des Yveline sur
dans son fauteuil de
sénateur on va entendre dans un instant
je vous le disais le doyen d'â bien
regagner vos places la séance est
reprise voici le résultat du scrutin
pour l'élection du président du Sénat
nombre de votants
348 bulletin blanc 22 bulletin nul 6
suffrage exprimé 320 majorité absolue
161 ont obtenu monsieur Gérard Larcher
20 218
[Applaudissements]
voix
ce n'est pas un votre par un vote par
acclamation donc je vais vous donner
quand même les scores des autres
candidats Monsieur Patrick canner a
obtenu 64
[Applaudissements]
voix
madame Cécile k kierman 20
[Applaudissements]
voix et monsieur Guillaume Gontard 18
voix donc Monsieur Gérard Larcher ayant
obtenu la majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimé au premier tour de scrutin je le
proclame élu président du Sénat et
conformément à l'article 1er du
règlement je l'invite à prendre place au
fauteuil de la présidence que je lui
cède bien volontiers et je remercie les
secrétaire d'âge pour leur participation
aux opérations de vote monsieur le
président
Monsieur le Doyen monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues secrétaire du
bureau chers collègues président de
groupe mes chers
collègues merci tout d'abord Monsieur le
Doyen cher Jean-Marie vanenberg pour vos
propos et la réflexion que vous nous
avez fait partager sur la
démocratie sur le par
sur la dimension sociétale et sociale de
notre action et pour la métaphore
maritime qui indiqué le bon
port je souhaite remercier les
secrétaires du bureau
d'âge fonction éphémère que j'ai connu
c'était il y a quelques années c'est un
moment un peu
particulier je voudrais souhaiter la
bienvenue à nos nouveaux collègues ils
deviennent les héritiers et les porteurs
du
bicamérisme du Conseil des Anciens de
1795 au Sénat d'aujourd'hui près de 230
années où notre pays n'a connu que trois
périodes sans deux assemblées
parlementaires la convention avant
octobre
1795 mais il y eu la terreur et la
nécessité du Conseil des Anciens la
deuxè République en
1848 mais qui après des début rempli
d'espérance et de liberté c'est'est
terminé par un coup d'État le 2 décembre
1852 et une période particulièrement
noire l'État français où le Parlement et
la République avait disparu mes chers
collègues le bicamérisme
est indispensable à notre démocratie
parlementaire je veux avoir une pensée
de gratitude pour celles et ceux qui ne
siègent plus parmi nous aujourd'hui ils
ont apporté au Sénat et au pays et vous
avez eu Monsieur le Doyen une pensée
particulière pour
eux permettez-moi de remercier très
sincèrement celles et ceux qui m'ont
témoigné leur confiance je m'engage à
présider notre assemblée avec la
légitimité que me donne la majorité mais
aussi dans le respect de vos diverses
sensibilités je vous propose de n'avoir
pour boussol que l'intérêt de notre pays
est de poursuivre la construction du
Sénat de demain je voudrais saluer
sincèrement Patrick canner c'est queman
et Guillaume Gontard les présidents de
groupe qui ont été candidats ils ont
témoigné de la pluralité de notre
assemblée je veux leur dire que je
seraiis comme hier très attentif au
respect des groupes minoritaires et
d'opposition comme d'ailleurs attentif à
chaque groupe politique et à chaque
sénateur où qu'il
siège oui il existe une manière
particulière au Sénat d'exercer la
fonction
parlementaire être sénatrice être
sénateur c'est faire vivre la démocratie
être au service de la République et des
citoyens quand 62 % des Français jugent
que le Sénat joue un rôle important dans
la vie politique française on mesure le
chemin parcouru depuis 9 années nous
incarnons plus que jamais ce pôle de
stabilité ce point d'équilibre que vous
avez souvent entendu évoquer oui je
pense que le Sénat est plus que jamais
au cœur de notre vie
démocratique être sénatrice être
sénateur c'est être autonome libre et
indépendant c'est aussi se respecter les
uns les autres c'est donner à nos
compatriotes le visage d'une assemblée
où on débat où on propose ou parfois on
s'oppose mais jamais dans le mépris
l'invective ou la violence mes chers
collègues il y a me semble-t-il une
façon sénatoriale de faire de la
politique avec
sérieux calme détermination c'est la
bonne méthode pour recoudre un pays
fracturé sans craindre de dire la vérité
même si elle dérange en ne reculant
jamais devant l'obstacle fort de ces
principes il nous faut imaginer et
construire ensemble le Sénat de demain
pour mieux répondre aux attentes de nos
concitoyens et des territoires pour
retrouver la confiance notre pays qui
souffre doute au fond qui n'a plus
confiance a besoin d'une assemblée
attentive j'ose le dire une assemblée
presque affective vis-à-vis de nos
compatriotes ces dernières années j'ai
sillonné le pays j'ai rencontré de
nombreux élus locaux et nombre d'acteurs
économiques et sociaux vous le sentez
bien nous traversons une crise
profonde aggravation des fractures
territoriales monté de l'abstention et
des votes
contestataires dégradation de services
public et de la présence médical envoler
de la dette publique et des déficits
monter des violences et des émutes
urbaines inquiétude au quotidien face à
l'inflation une jeunessequ est-elle
aussi notamment face au défis
climatiques nous l'avons tous ressenti
pendant la campagne électoral pour ceux
qui étaient candidats que nous venons de
vivre il nous faudra rompre avec cette
spirale du déclin et le Sénat devra y
prendre toute sa
part mes chers
collègues c'est le sens du projet pour
les TR années à venir que j'ai fait
parvenir à chacune et à chacun d'entre
vous
le Sénat de la République aujourd'hui et
demain d'abord notre mission
constitutionnelle le président de la
République a par deux fois en 2017 et en
2022 annoncé son intention de procéder à
une réforme des institutions j'ai
souhaité à chaque fois que le Sénat soit
en
anticipation notre groupe de travail
transpartisan se réunit depuis novembre
202 de et il fera des propositions d'ici
la fin de cette année nous sommes prêts
à envisager toute réforme qui serait
utile à l'amélioration du fonctionnement
de notre démocratie si elle permet de
recoudre le pays si elle permet au
peuple de retrouver la confiance en ses
parlementaires ses gouvernants sa
justice mais je le dis je le redis notre
Constitution ne se modifie pas en
fonction des pulsions du moment
[Applaudissements]
la
loi vous êtes des législateurs
elle est le cœur de notre
mission ces trois dernières années au
travers de notre mission de législateur
nous avons défendu ensemble dans la
diversité de nos groupes politiques les
prérogatives du Parlement face à toutes
les tentatives de contour
nous avons lutté contre le recours
excessif aux ordonnances qui dépossèd le
Parlement du débat et du droit
d'amendement la loi pour retrouver sa
force et son efficacité doit obéir à
quelques
principes
simplicité
lisibilité
efficacité subsidiarité il nous faut
donc moins légiférer pour mieux
légiférer et cela nous concerne tous
exécutif comme nous tous dans chacune de
nos assemblées pour atteindre cet
objectif qui me paraît
[Applaudissements]
essentiel trop de lois ne sont jamais
appliqué ou
inefficace n devons les évaluer avant et
après vote l'annonce d'un projet de loi
est trop souvent devenu un outil de
communication pour les réseaux sociaux
et les médias
méfions-nous des lois de pulsion qui
produisent cette inflation législative
qu'il nous faut
combattre notre ion de
contrôle elle est essentielle au
contrepouvoir que nous incarnons nous
avons été fidèles à l'esprit des lois
oui le pouvoir doit arrêter le pouvoir
c'est ce qu'écrivait Montesquieu et la
société a droit de demander compte à
tout agent public de son administration
c'est l'article 15 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen c'est ce
que nous avons fait au cours de ces tro
années c'est ce que nous ferons
enfin nous portons la voix des
territoires convaincu que la gouvernance
verticale la
suradministration l'hyper concentration
du pouvoir sont en partie à l'origine
des mots dont souffre notre pays nous
devons remettre les maires au cœur de la
décision gérer en proximité imposer
nouveau souffle de décentralisation mais
à décentralisation forte il faut un état
territorial fort nos collectivités ont
besoin de plus de liberté c'est vrai
pour les communes c'est vrai pour les
départements c'est vrai pour les régions
il nous faudra trouver un juste
équilibre entre différenciation et unité
de la
République le 6 juillet
dernier 15 propos pour rendre aux élus
le pouvoir d'agir ont été rendu public
et adressé au Président de la République
et à la première
ministre
simplification autonomie fiscale et
financière statut de l'élu relation
entre les services de l'État et les
maires logement et bien d'autres points
encore c'est donc une main tendue
loyalement et concrètement par le Sénat
à l'exécutif je souhaite que l'exécutif
saisisse cette main
[Applaudissements]
tendue en ces temps où l'équilibre
institutionnel a été profondément
modifié du fait de l'absence de majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale où le fait
majoritaire n'est plus le Sénat a un
rôle essentiel dans le fonctionnement
nos
institution il est parvenu à être le
point d'équilibre d'une démocratie à la
peine
une assemblée qui assume ses différences
qui résiste à la désinformation parfois
alarmante à la justice
expéditive des réseaux
sociaux Michel Debray l' anticipé déjà
devant le Conseil d'État je le cite
c'éit en août
1958 il est facile de comprendre
pourquoi il faut à la France une
puissante 2e chambre notre régime
électoral peut nous empêcher de
connaître les majorité cohérente qui
assure sans règle détaillé la bonne
marche du régime parlementaire c'est
donc aujourd'hui pour nous une
responsabilité supplémentaire et pour la
première fois d'ailleurs réellement
depuis
1958 la démocratie représentative mes
chers collègues est fragile il faut en
prendre soin attention à l'image que
nous projetons dans l'opinion faisons la
vivre en étant ouvert disponible à
l'écoute soyons attentif au pou de la
société à l'extérieur du pays n'ai un
doute sur le rôle et le rend de la
France dans le monde j'ai dans mes
déplacements à l'étranger rencontrer nos
compatriotes établis hors de France nous
devons y être particulièrement attentifs
à ces compatriotes et être solidaire je
pense aujourd'hui à ce que nous vivons à
ce qu'il vivent en Afrique soyons
attentifs aux puissances nouvelles qui
émerg sur le continent africain et en
indopacifique et qui bouleverse des
équilibres qui semblaient durablement
être
installés nous devons faire face à de
nouveaux défis crise migratoire crise
climatique sur lesqueles nous devons
être
particulièrement mobilisé vast champ où
la démocratie mais surtout la dipl
diplomatie parlementaire peut être utile
je veux mes chers collègues avoir une
pensée toute particulière et solidaire
en cette
journée du 2 octobre pour l'Arménie et
les Arméniens qui ont le sentiment
qu'ils sont à nouveau bien seuls et
qu'ils sachent que nous sommes à leur
côté
ensemble nous allons vivre 3 années
d'engagement au service des Français au
service de la République je crois
profondément que le Sénat aura une
responsabilité particulière pour
mobiliser les forces vives de notre pays
et faire vivre la démocratie nous
devrons rester l'assemblée du b apaisé
une assemblée responsable face au défis
qui se présente intransigente à chaque
fois que les intérêts de la France
l'exigeront c'est comme cela que nous
réussirons à rassembler les Français
pour retrouver un sentiment commun
d'appartenance à la nation oui nous
devons retrouver confiance et espérance
alors ce que je vous propose c'est de
participer ensemble à cette ambition
collective N avons une responsabilité
particulière pour les 3 années qui
viennent une responsabilité que nous
devrons assumer dans la diversité de ce
que nous sommes de ce que nous
représentons que nous soyons en
métropole dans nos outresmers quelque
part nous incarnons une France qui
connaît chers doyen son cap qui doit
tenir son cap le cap c'est l'intérêt de
la France pour que vive le Sénat vive la
république et vive la France
[Applaudissements]
merci
encore mes chers collègues je vous
propose de confirmer par consensus c'est
aussi un élément de notre culture le
calendrier de la suite du renouvellement
des instances du Sénat tel qu'Il vous a
été communiqué y a-t-il des
oppositions je n'en vois point il en est
ainsi décidé j'attire votre attention
sur l'importance de votre
présence et de votre
ponctualité pour la réalisation de la
photographie officielle du Sénat dans
l'hémicycle le jeudi 5
octobre si vous n'êtes pas là il y a pas
de réinjection de photos et pendant 3
ans on ne voit pas vos visages partout
ce serait malheureux donc je souhaite
vraiment que vous soyez là je rappelle
le 5 octobre à
14h30 l'ordre du jour des prochaine
semaine sera fixé par la Conférence des
présidents qui se réunira jeudi prochain
à
18h pas de motion particulière je vous
remercie la séance est levée
ouais làhaut voilà donc Gérard Larcher
donc réélu président du Sénat avec 218
voix qui a été acclamé par l'ensemble de
l'hémicycle et on va tout de suite
rejoindre Mathias Arz dans la tribune
une de presse du Sénat pour revenir et
bien sur ce discours de Gérard Larcher
qui s'est exprimé une petite vingtaine
de minutes voilà c'est un Gérard Larcher
qui a bien vite retrouvé ses habitudes
qui vient de quitter l'hémicycle alors
avec
218 voix c'est un Gérard Larché réélu
pour la 5e fois qui a pris la parole
debout sur depuis son siège du plateau
le président reconduit à pendant donc
une vingtaine de minutes à déroul sur le
programme de son mandat pour les trois
prochaines années un mandat sous le
signe du contrepouvoir un mot qu'il n'a
toutefois pas prononcé mais qu'il a
induit à travers quelques phrases
quelques sailis à l'encontre du de
l'exécutif un un sénat qui ne doit pas
céder à l'inflation législative il l'a
prononcé il faudrait légiférer moins
mais légiférer mieux un sénat symbole de
stabilité et qui aura donc un rôle
central dans les années à venir archie
qui entend à l'oré de son 5e mandat créé
il a répété deux fois le Sénat de
demain merci merci beaucoup Mathias
tandis que l'on voit Gérard Larcher
voilà qui
s'avance là dans la salle des
conférences du Sénat saluer félicité par
les galeries des bustes pardon félicité
par les uns et les autres voilà le
nouveau président du Sénat Gerard
l'archer élu avec 218 voix Valérie Boyer
votre réaction voilà à la réélection de
Gérard Larché bon ce n'était pas une
surprise c'était prévu d'avance 218 voix
c'est un petit peu moins toutefois qu'il
y a qu'il y a 3 ans mais le président du
Sénat que l'on a vu être acclamé par
l'ensemble de l'hémicycle cet après-midi
bah c'est une
personnalité incroyable de la vie
politique française Gérard Larcher son
son parcours le fait qu'il soit apprécié
de l'ensemble des groupes qu'il arrive à
travailler et à parler avec tout le
monde parce que c'est à la fois
quelqu'un qui est fidèle à sa famille
politique et qui est apprécié par tous
euh et qui en plus incarne le Sénat et a
un petit peu sauveré le Sénat de de ceux
qui voulaient le détruire et en
rappelant quand même comme il l'a fait
dans son discours à la fois la place et
le rôle du Sénat dans la vie
démocratique française donc c'est c'est
éminemment important je rappelle que
c'est quand même le deuxième personnage
de l'État
et que c'est une grande satisfaction je
crois pour en tout cas pour moi-même
pour l'ensemble des sénateurs de son
groupe et même pour l'ensemble des
sénateurs enfin je veux pas parler à la
place de mes collègues mais d'avoir un
président qui a cette envergure ce sens
de l'État ce sens de de de la démocratie
et du dialogue je crois que c'est
vraiment un modèle pour la vie politique
française et qu'il marquera non
seulement l'histoire du Sénat mais
l'histoire de la vie politique française
euh Yan Chantrel Gérard Larcher qui a
insisté he lors de ce discours sur
l'importance que l'assemblée que le
Sénat reste l'assemblée du débat apaisé
il a également dit qu'il fallait
absolument prendre soin de la démocratie
représentative c'est un discours dans
lequel vous vous retrouvez aujourd'hui
alors qu'effectivement euh et bien la
démocratie représentative n'est pas
n'est pas toujours félicitée par les
Français oui tout à fait bah après déjà
le féliciter le le président de l'arché
de manière républicaine bien évidemment
puisqu'il est le président de de de
notre institution qui se doit de
défendre aussi nos prérogatives et des
fois on est un peu mal mené hein par le
gouvernement on l'a vu lors de la
réforme des retraites notamment donc je
pense que il se doit aussi d'être le
garant de nos pouvoirs c'est important
le Parlement en France dans un pouvoir
qui est à mes yeux beaucoup trop
présidentiel mais ça ça sera un autre
débat parce que nous on veut plutôt
modifier changer les institutions et
quand j'écoute j'ai l'impression que ça
ça ça va devenir peut-être le futur
candidat de la droite quand on voit ce
qui se passe là à moins que à moins
qu'il ne devienne peut-être le premier
ministre du d'Emmanuel Macron lui-même
ce qu'on ce qu'on entend aussi dans les
couloirs ce qu'on entend aussi dans les
couloirs du Sénat je j'en sais rien mais
je sais que c'est c'est dire quand même
l'importance centrale de Gérard Larcher
parce que ces rumeurs existaient déjà il
y a plusieurs années donc maintenant
c'est aussi crédible que si Olivier fort
était premier ministre de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui lui-même serait président
donc Ctait
je pense je pense que comp raison n'est
pas raison chers collègu mais
que non mais le fait que le nom de
Gérard Larcher revienne régulièrement
euh et que ce soit une personnalité
centrale de la vie politique française
je c'est ça tient à la façon dont il a
de de gérer le Sénat ça tient à la façon
dont il entretient des relations avec
l'ensemble des hommes et des femmes
politiques de ce pays et puis aussi à
son enracinement qui est très fort donc
oui je pense que c'est un personnage
très important et et encore une fois je
renouvelle toutes mes félicitations et
et toute ma joie de et bien de siéger
comme sénateur avec lui comme président
et dans notre famille politique c'est la
revanche de de l'Ancien Monde Gérard
Larcher he qui qui perdure réélu depuis
2008 avec cette encrage territoriale
avec cette façon de faire de la de la
politique vous vous vous reconnaissez
aussi làdedans dans ce parcours sa viier
yovelli c'est un ce n'est pas forcément
euh alors vous savez moi j'ai commencé
ma carrière politique dans l'ancien
monde donc je ne suis pas un enfant de
2017 plutôt un enfant de de 2002 et un
grand brûlet d'ailleurs de du 21 avril
2002 donc oui je me reconnais dans dans
dans ce parcours et et et c'est tout à
son honneur enfin je veux dire ça a été
un élu local maire d'une grande ville et
d'une belle ville qui est rambouillé euh
moi je vois Gérard Larcher aussi un
président qui respecte l'ensemble des
des groupes politiques et l'ensemble des
minorités et ça je pense que c'est
important euh comme l'a dit mon collègue
quand on est président des secrets pour
durer aussi he est président depuis
quand on est quand on est maire quand on
est maire par exemple on est maire de
tous les citoyens quel que soit leur
appartenance politique et quel que soit
leur choix au moment des élections et
ben quand on est président du Sénat on
est président effectivement de tous les
sénateur et je pense que c'est ce qui
fait aussi sa force et après c'est
l'ancien monde mais c'est un peu aussi
le Sénat qui est comme ça ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est que c'est Debré
qui disait que quand il disait à de Gaul
quand il a écrit la Constitution on
pourra va perdre toutes les élections
sauf le Sénat et c'est un peu un peu le
cas la seule fois où il y a où le Sénat
est passé à gauche il rest 2014 donc
voyez donc je pense que effectivement le
Sénat le mode d'élection fait que il y a
une part importante des des zones
rurales qui dans dans dans notre dans
notre assemblée et donc plutôt
conservatrice et c'est pour ça que que
on reste sur cette identité politique
mais globalement je pense que c'est
aussi une quelle que soit l'étiquette
politique de l'Assemblée nationale le
Sénat reste un contrepouvoir parce que
ça on on est libre on n pas lié
directement au président de la
République on peut être en fidélité
comme je le suis mais on n'est pas lié
électoralement au président de la
République et je pense que ça c'est
important d'avoir cette liberté Emmanuel
Capu d'ailleurs jérard Larchet a dit que
vous étiez autonome libre indépendant
les indépendants c'est le nom de votre
groupe vous vous êtes sorti très à
l'aise avec cette définition j'ai même
j'ai même eu l'impression qu'il
regardait le président maluray quand il
a prononcé ses termes donc oui je me
reconnais tout à fait dans ces termes je
félicite d'ailleurs le président Larcher
pour lequel j'ai voté comme je pense la
totalité
des membres de mon groupe même si le le
scrutin est est secret mais je pense que
c'est ce qui s'est
passé moi le le le le le le Sénat aussi
a voté pour lui mais ce n'était pas un
secret non plus le Sénat incarne la
stabilité sec et Gérard larch incarne le
Sénat donc il y a une c'est tout à fait
logique qu'on ait cette stabilité à la
présidence du Sénat et qui aussi la
reconnaissance du du fait que je crois
que c'est un président qui a été quand
même à la hauteur au moment où on a eu
on a traversé quand même un paquet
ou le covid les retraites euh la crise
les crises internationales et à chaque
fois je pense le président Larcher a été
vraiment au rendez-vous il a pris de la
hauteur la hauteur que
que qui est celle du siège qu'il occupe
il a essayé de réunir au-delà des
clivages partisans et on le voit son
score va bien au-delà du socle LR
et et et UC mais donc je pense que c'est
c'est le fruit de cette de cette
personnalité qui incarne les territoires
en fait et nous n nous sommes les
représentants des territoires ici et
tout de suite et bien justement Gérard
Larcher le président du Sénat qui vient
donc d'être réélu avec 218 voix est au
micro de Quentin c'est à VOUS Quentin
effctivement 210 VO bonjour Gérard LCH
vous êtes élu pour la 5e fois au poste
de président du Sénat un mot sur ce que
vous avez ressenti sur ce que vous vous
êtes dit au moment de la proclamation
des résultats beaucoup d'émotions encore
une fois parce que recevoir une très
large confiance qui dépasse même les
clivages des deux groupes de la majorité
sénatoriale c'est ça me donne des
devoirs des devoirs d'abord de cette
confiance reçue mais aussi des devoirs
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des groupes du
Sénat et de l'ensemble des sénateurs
vous savez je je souhaite vraiment
que le Sénat qui a un rôle particulier
dans cette période je l'exliquis à mes
collègues sénateurs il y a pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale ici il
y a une majorité il y a une assemblée
qui est en capacité de débattre
d'amender de s'opposer de dire oui et je
dois dire que cette responsabilité là il
faut qu'on l'assume pour le pays en
fabriquant mieux la loi en contrôlant le
gouvernement et en oubliant jamais que
nous procédons de la trape des 500000
élus territoriaux qui sont le ciment de
notre pays mais estce que sur le plan
personnelle vous vous êtes fait une
réflexion en particulier il y a cette
longévité 5è fois élu à ce poste
qu'est-ce que personnellement vous vous
êtes dit que j'avais le même
enthousiasme que la première fois le
même désir et j'allais dire le même
bonheur et
que la 5e fois c'est comme la première
fois c'est une responsabilité que je
reçois par la confiance de mes collègues
vous avez parler hein du Sénat point
d'équilibre de la République c'est ce
que vous aviez dit dès le soir de
l'élection sénatoriale du 24 septembre
vous l'avez redit dans votre discours
c'est quoi c'est ce point d'équilibre de
nos institutions et de la République en
quoi est-ce que le Sénat est
indispensable est-ce que vous diriez que
vous avez participé du changement de
l'image du Sénat aujourd'hui je crois
qu'on a tous participé les 348 sénateurs
347 en dehors de moi ils ont tous
participé par cette image de d'assemblée
à la fois on va au fond des choses mais
en même temps qu'il y a des débats
apaisés et qui mesure parfois qu'il faut
dire non quand c'est l'intérêt du pays
le doyen tout à l'heure emprunté une
métaphore maritime voyz je l'ai reprise
je crois que nous devons nous donner une
boussole et cette boussole c'est
l'intérêt du pays vous êtes élu pour la
5è fois au poste de président du S vous
avez un message à l'exécutif est-ce que
vous adressez aujourd'hui un message en
particulier à Emmanuel Macron vous a
entendu très
vément concerne la décentralisation il
faut un nouveau ch nous lui avons fait
une
proposition j'ai renouvelé cette
proposition à le président de la
République nous a
renvoyé un certain nombre de réflexions
je viens de lui répondre et je pense que
ce sujet de la décentralisation c'est
pas simplement en quelque sorte pour
plaire aux élus c'est parce que notre
pays en a besoin notre pays ne pourra
pas se redresser sans ces territoires ou
contre ces territoires c'est pour moi
quelque chose de tout à fait essentiel
nous avons besoin des territoires certes
il n'y a pas que la politique
territoriale il y a un ensemble de
sujets que j'ai abordé dans mon propos
qui soit intérieur qui soi les grands
sujets de crise migratoire climatique
inflation problème aussi de la politique
de santé tout ceci le Sénat souhaite
vraiment aider le pays être à l'écoute
du pays et il faut que l'exécutif nous
entende partage et surtout respecte le
Parlement un mot sur l'un des principaux
textes qui va arriver cet automne le
projet de loi immigration quelle est
votre approche puisqu'on sait que c'est
le Sénat qui va examiner ce texte en
premier est-ce que vous dites à
l'exécutif de retirer l'article 3 mais
ce texte métion ce texte il est euh
devant la commission des lois il a déjà
été examiné chacun sait les réserves
absolues euh que nous avons sur les
articles 3 et 4 euh je le redis et c'est
ma position nous avons plus de 430000
chômeurs étrangers à un moment où la
question de l'intégration est majeure
occupons-nous déjà de reconduire ces
étrangers qui résident régulièrement en
France vers le travail et nous ferons
une bonne œuvre et pour l'économie et
pour l'intégration on arrive à la fin de
cette interview jardch si vous voulez
bien je vais vous poser une question sur
la Corse car le chef de l'État a fait
des annonces en ce sens jeudi il veut
que l'île de Beauté rentre dans la
Constitution avec ses spécificités
historiques linguistique et culturel
jusqu'où la droite sénatoriale est-elle
prêt à aller dans et bien cette
construction d'un accord avec les alu
Corse d'abord je recevrai les deux
sénateurs cors très rapidement et je
recevrai le président Siméoni
la semaine prochaine chef de l'exécutif
Corse vous savez on a quelques principes
je l'ai dit dans mon discours oui à la
différenciation mais dans l'unité de la
République allez j'ai une dernière
question je si vous le voulez bien on
vous a vu en grande conversation avec
Mick Jer la semaine dernière à
Versailles et des personnes se demandent
ce que vous vous disiez avec le rocker à
ce momentl à Versailles ça a fait
beaucoup de buzz sur les réseaux sociaux
est-ce que vous pouvez nous confier ce
que vous disiez à ce moment-là en tous
les cas nous avons beaucoup évoqué le
valde Loire car il a une résidence dans
le Val de Loire et je lui expliqué qu'il
y avait une partie de l'âme française et
que c'était une âme française souvent
apaisée ce qui n'empêchait pas d'avoir
beaucoup de rythme le long de la Loire
voilà ça vous a amusé cà c'était un bon
moment et être le voisin de son épouse
était un excellent moment aussi voilà
très bien et bien merci Monsieur Larcher
pour cette réaction au micro de public s
merci beaucoup merci merci beaucoup
Quentin pour cette C interview de Gérard
Larcher voilà juste après sa réélection
Gérard Larcher qui a donc été réélu
président du Sénat avec 218 voix à
l'instant il a été acclamé par
l'ensemble de l'hémicycle je suis à
présent avec le président du groupe
écologiste Guillaume Gontard bonjour
vous étiez également candidat au plateau
vous avez fait le plein de vos voix 18
le groupe écologiste peut-être votre
réaction tout de même à la réélection du
président président du Sénat Gérard
Larcher céit un peu couru d'avance voilà
on va dire qu'il y avait pas une grande
surprise mais d'abord mes félicitations
républicaines à Gérard Larcher pour ce
5e mandat quand même c'est c'est vrai
que c'est un exploit un exploit de
longévité élu depuis 2008 à la comme
présidente du Sénat exactement après
c'était évidemment normal que les les
groupes d'opposition présentent une une
candidature et moi j'étais très fier de
de représenter de représenter les
écologistes pour cette cette élection au
Sénat ce que je constate c'est que on
progresse alors oui fait 13 voix euh il
y a il y a 3 ans 18 voix cette fois
cette fois-ci mais ça montre quoi ça
montre que les écologistes s'installe on
a un groupe qui se conforte et qui se
conforte dans la durée au Sénat on n
jamais eu un groupe aussi important au
Sénat je pense que c'est ça aussi qu'il
faut qu'il faut retenir on n' jamais eu
autant de parlementaires que ça soit au
Sénat ou à l'Assemblée à l'Assemblée
nationale euh et donc c'est aussi le
miroir de ce qui se passe dans nos
territoires euh l'écologie euh bah elle
est là ce sont des élus partout euh dans
les zones rurales dans les zones
urbaines qui sont qui sont qui sont
présents et et que nous représentons
évidemment au Sénat et parmi les
symboles peut-être il y a notamment
l'élection de la benjamine du Sénat
Mathie d'Olivier qu'on a beaucoup vu cet
après-midi hein puisqu'elle elle était à
côté de l'urne dans laquelle vous avez
tous voté elle est aussi peut-être
l'emblème et bien de ce renouvellement
des générations et de cette féminisation
aussi qui est progressive qui va
lentement mais qui arrive celle du Sénat
une grande fierté c'est vrai parce que
ce groupe je le dis il est renforcé
largement renforcé mais aussi largement
féminisé puis rajuni aussi avec Mathilde
Olivier c'est vrai que élu sénatrices et
français de de de l'étranger mais c'est
vrai que c'est ce qu'on souhaitait et
c'est ce qu'on a voulu aussi dans dans
ces dans ces candidature au sénatorial
c'est faire en sorte que ce groupe ben
évidemment devienne plus fort mais aussi
soit plus jeune et plus féminisé bah
c'est ce que nous avons réussi et nous
accueillons également un nouveau
sénateur sur ce plateau bonjour et
bienvenue Louison bonjour bonjour vous
êtes sénateurs les indépendants de la
scène etmarne ancien maire de Melin un
mot sur peut-être et bien ce à quoi vous
venez d'assister c'est-à-dire l'élection
du président du Sénat la réélection de
Gérard Larcher dans un moment quand même
assez solennel assez codifié et puis et
bien un mot sur la réaction de gerérles
archer qui qui fait preuve d'une grande
longévité à ce poste oui oui oui mais je
me retrouve tout à fait dans dans son
discours euh il a il a parlé d'un
certain nombre de de de sujets qui ont
été les sujets de de ma campagne oui on
voit bien que les territoires ont ont
besoin d'être qu'on leur fasse confiance
et
que les les maires les élus locaux on
ont besoin de soutien et un certain
nombre de choses discours assez offensif
he sur la question de la
décentralisation de oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai parce que on narrête pas de parler
notre pays est traditionnellement le le
plus centralisé du monde possible mais
et on narrête pas de parler de
décentralisation et chaque fois on en
redemande plus parce qu'en fait il se
recentralise au fur et à mesure et la la
demande des des élus locaux c'est
véritablement qu'on en fasse confiance
et que il y ait une vraie
décentralisation des des pouvoirs dans
les collectivités territoriales on va
aller tout de suite salle des
conférences rejoindre un are indépendant
le premier d'entre eux peut-être c'est
le président du groupe Claude manur qui
est tout au micro de Quentin Calmet
Quentin vous êtes donc avec Claude
maluret c'est à VOUS bonjour Claude
maluret à une réaction tout d'abord à la
réélection de Gérard lynchet au plateau
ce n'est pas une surprise mais qu'est-ce
que ça vous évoque vous cette
réélection comm comme vous le dites ça
n'est pas du tout du tout une surprise
euh et ce qui est encore moins une
surprise c'est de voir que de constater
que l'élection de relâcher réuni
beaucoup plus de souffrage que sa
majorité que la majorité sénatoriale
c'est-à-dire que sa personne personalité
son sens du dialogue de l'écoute avec
l'ensemble des sénateurs est salué par
cette élection qui est une élection tout
à fait confortable le groupe que vous
présidez les indépendants républiqu et
territoire le groupe de la droite Macron
compatible ainsi que le groupe RDPI le
groupe Renaissance au Sénat n'ont pas
présenté de candidat face à Gérard larch
pourquoi quand les choses marchent bien
il y a pas de raison de les réparer et
par conséquentérard larch est un très
bon Président du
Sénat est il est dans l'opposition au
gouvernement mais dans une opposition
constructive on le voit encore plus
depuis que l'Assemblée nationale est
dans une situation de blocage
aujourd'hui le Sénat est une opposition
raisonnée qui dialogue avec le
gouvernement c'est d'ailleurs ce que
Gérard arché a dit dans son discours et
dans ces conditions pourquoi lui opposer
qui que ce soit alors d'ici demain on
devrait connaître la composition exacte
des groupes politique on aura le nombre
de chaque groupe politique combien de
sénateurs par siège est-ce que vous êtes
en mesure de donner votre nom de
sénateurs vous nous sommes un peu moins
de 20 sénateurs mais comme tout peut
changer jusqu'au dernier moment je j'ai
pas le chiffre exact mais on est passé
de 14 sénateurs à quelque chose entre 18
et 20 est-ce que ça dit quelque chose de
ce qui se joue au Sénat un sénat plus au
centre avec 10 allaires en moins par
exemple au groupe les républicains ça ça
dit quelque chose même très lentement
même à la marge de ce qui se joue au
Sénat euh je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse
parler de euh de façon géographique
comme vous le faites moi pour moi c'est
un succès
des indépendants et d'horizon puisque
beaucoup des sénateurs qui ont qui qui
rejointent notre groupe aujourd'hui sont
des sénateur horizon ça témoigne de
l'implantation d'horizon dans les
communes puisque c'est une implantation
territoriale qui fait qui qui qui vote
pour les sénateurs ce sont des des des
élus des territoires et c'est pour moi
le succès comme à l'Assemblée nationale
il y a un an de l'implantation de
d'horizon dans les territoires et dans
les communes etdard Philippe aussi vous
le dites B quand je dis horizon je dis
édard Philippe bien entendu très bien et
bien merci merci Claude maluret pour
cette réaction au micro de public on
suivra bien sûr les dernier résultat sur
la composition des groupes politiques
demain puisqu'ils son ils seront rendus
officiel à ce moment-là Tam si merci
beaucoup Quentin pour cette nouvelle
réaction celle du président du groupe
Les Indépendants Claude maluret tantis
que j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau Dominique estr Sasson bonjour
bonjour sénatrice les républicains des
Alpes Maritimes on peut toujours dire
vice-présidente du groupe les
républicains depuis la semaine dernière
j'ai de nouveau une autre collègue qui a
pris la suite des 6 ans que j'ai occupé
en ma qualité de vice-présidente du
groupe les républicains Dominique estros
Sasson votre réaction à la réélection de
Gérard Larché ce n'était pas une
surprise mais tout de même on l'a
entendu là Gérard Larcher qui a adressé
à nouveau ce message au au sénateurs sur
la défense notamment de la démocratie
représentative et on l'a vu acclamer par
sur l'ensemble des bancs du Sénat cet
après-midi oui je tiens bien sûr à à
saluer la réélection de Gérard Larcher
par un très beau score on voit combien
la personnalité de Gérard lcher
rassemble largement au-delà de la
famille de la droite et du centre8 voix
hein parce que je crois que Gérard arché
incarne parfaitement notre institution
et il défend parfaitement le bicamérisme
il y a d'ailleurs fait référence dans le
cadre de son discours et puis c'est un
fin connaisseur de nos territoires dans
leur diversité en prenant en compte
leurs spécificités et je crois que ça
aujourd'hui dans un contexte dans un
monde politique et dans une société qui
est extrêmement fracturé
territorialement économiquement
socialement c'est particulièrement
appréciable et ça continue à faire du
Sénat au travers de geréralarché un pôle
de stabilité institutionnelle quels sont
pour vous les les nouveaux défis de ce
nouveau Sénat alors qu'on est et bien
avec un renouvellement du Sénat et
toujours avec B cette relation avec
l'Assemblée nationale où le gouvernement
a donc perdu sa majorité absolue à quoi
le Sénat va devoir prêter attention sur
cette nouvelle mandature je ti de le
dire rester véritablement un pôle de
stabilité institutionnelle face à ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
nationale non seulement avec une
majorité relative mais aussi
malheureusement avec une un certain
nombre de députés qui donc vcifè plus
qu'il ne travaille et quand on voit les
travaux de la façon dont il se déroulent
au Sénat avec beaucoup de sérieux dans
l'apaisement dans le respect les uns des
autres en affirmant également nos
convictions je pense que c'est
véritablement une image une plusvalue
qu'apporte le Sénat à notre démocratie
et puis le deuxème c'est d'être un
contre-pouvoir mais un contre-pouvoir
exigeant un contre-pouvoir qui fait en
sorte que bien évidemment ce qui sort du
Sénat puisse comme l'a dit Gérard
Larcher que la main tendue soit
effectivement prise par l'exécutif et
par la majorité présidentielle parce que
effectivement je pense que c'est de
comme cela que l'on arrivera à recoudre
notre démocratie parlementaire qui est
relativement bien abîmée et surtout plus
important encore la démocratie de
proximité Guillaume Gontard est-ce que
vous vous retrouvez dans le message de
Gérard alarcher effectivement qui a
parlé de contrepouvoir dès le soir de sa
réélection vous qui êtes dans dans
l'opposition ici au Sénat bah dans dans
son message politique non je peux dire
que je me'y suis pas totalement
totalement retrouvé sur la place du
Sénat évidemment je pense que le Sénat
comme contrepouvoir le bicamérisme oui
on est tous on est tous d'accord après
ça c'est voilà c'est c'est la mécanique
interne maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait et quelle politique on porte et
c'est vrai que j'entendais Gérard
Larcher parler de l'autonomie des
collectivité de leur laisser plus de de
liberté de possibilités pour cela et ben
il faut aussi plus de liberté fiscale il
faut qu'elle puisse avoir la main sur
leur fiscalité c'est qu Mme c'est unjet
qui peut faire consensus au Sénat quand
même quelque chose sur lequel la
majorité sénatoriale s'est attaqué en
supprimant la la CVAE la contbition des
des entrebrises pour les pour les
collectivité on a eu la suppression la
la taxe d'habitation de la majorité
présidentielle mais je dirais que toute
cette lignée et toutes les choses qui
sont appliquées dans notre pays ont été
validées par la majorité sénatoriale euh
donc on le voit bien et on voit bien
d'ailleurs qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'opposition à Gérard Larcher dans les
autres groupes que ça soit RDPI que ça
soit le groupe des indépendants il n'y a
pas eu de d'opposition il n'a pas eu de
candidat ou de candidat face à Gérard
Larché donc on voit bien qu'on est dans
quelque chose
voilà on va dire que le Sénat devient un
petit peu le une manière de négocier
aussi avec avec le gouvernement et ça
devient de plus en plus le cas c'est un
peu la la chambre des négociations entre
les républicains et puis la majorité
présidentielle car il y a une
particularité ici Louis Vogel c'est
qu'on peut avoir un pied dans la
majorité sénatoriale et un pied dans la
majorité présidentielle vous en êtes
l'exemple c'est le cas de l'ensemble du
groupe Les Indépendants exactement et je
je pense que ça le Sénat c'est c'est la
chambre des territoires et dans les
Territoires on essaie de faire avancer
les choses gcher un mot très juste et a
parl de d'être constructif et nous on
est bien obligé quand on gère une
collectivité territoriale on est bien
obligé d'être constructif on essaie de
faire sortir les projets moi j'ai j'ai
souvent dit M citoyen un hôpital il a
pas de couleur politique on a déjà
tellement de mal à le réaliser cet
hôpital que on va pas se poser 36000
questions c'est quand même une assemblée
politique le Sénat mais bien sûr c'est
une assemblée politique mais c'est
politique au bon sens du terme
c'est-à-dire on est pour faire avancer
les choses et c'est pour ça que nous
nous sentons très bien au Sénat moi je
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure je me suis
reconnu dans ce discours du président du
Sénat et j'ai aucune contradiction avec
ça je suis comme l'a dit Claude maluret
tout à l'heure donc je soutiens tout à
fait cette cette cette prise de position
je trouve qu'il y a énormément de choses
à faire dans ce pays je pense qu'il y a
une grande demande de changement et si
on veut réaliser le changement il faut
qu'on travaille tous ensemble donc avec
le et avec le gouvernement donc je me
sens très très bien au Sénat au groupe
des indépendant et en lien avec la
majorité présidentielle et c'est
exactement le positionnement d'Édouard
Philippe aujourd'hui Dominique Estrosi
Sasson alors cette séance qui étit sans
surprise c'est aussi le coup d'envoi de
la session parlementaire va y avoir des
textes importants c'est l'automne
budgétaire c'est assez traditionnel il
va aussi avoir le projet de loi sur
l'immigration on a entendu la voix très
claire de Gérard Larcher là-dessus de ce
texte qui est déjà passé devant la
commission des lois qui va arriver en
séance le 6 novembre il dit l'article 3
l'article 4 du projet de loi sur
l'immigration c'est non pour pour la
droite sénatoriale notamment sur la
question de la régularisation des
étrangers en situation irrégulière qui
occupe un métier en tenstion oui en tout
cas pour le groupe les républicains
effectivement dans le projet de loi de
l'immigration la question de la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
titre de séjour y compris dans les
métiers en tension pour nous n'est pas
négociable parce que nous considérons
qu'il faut d'abord donner la priorité à
un certain nombre de nos compatriotes
qui aujourd'hui sont au chômage qui ne
trouvent pas directement un emploi
peut-être effectivement renforcer leur
formation mais aujourd'hui on créerait
un véritable appel d'air en régularisant
les travailleurs qui donc occupent des
métiers tention mais j'entends certains
aussi qui disent il faut régulariser
tous les travailleurs qui sont donc sans
titre de séjour et de façon irrégulière
dans notre pays donc nous nous voulons
d'abord donner la priorité aux Français
et aux Français et donc nous voulons un
texte qui mette en avant la fermeté la
fermeté face à l'immigration irrégulière
et là-dessus effectivement ce n'est pas
négociable en tout cas c'est ce qui a
déjà été voté par la commission des lois
quand le texte devait être soumis à
notre assemblée il y a quelques mois de
cela ça va être le grand sujet test
Guillaume gontar hein l'immigration voir
si et bien la majorité présidentielle va
s'aligner sur la droite sénatoriale en
commençant le texte par ici par le Sénat
c'est exactement ce que je disais on
voit bien c'est c'est le lieu des
négociations entre les républicains et
la majorité présidentielle donc le Sénat
est devenu et devenu ça donc nous on
regarde on observe ce qui se passe je
pense qu' on arrivera certainement sur
un accord entre entre les deux nous on
est évidemment totalement à la fois
opposé à à rien que l'essence même de ce
de ce texte moi je pense qu'il y a une
chose qui est certaine c'est que le
droit au travail inconditionnel ça me
paraît quelque chose d'indispensable je
vois pas comment on peut priver une
personne de travailler puisque le privé
de travailler c'est le privé de se
nourrir de se loger d'exister même donc
je pense que ce droit au travail
inconditionnel il est évident et que
notre politique migratoire telle qu'elle
est faite aujourd'hui euh et je dirais
alors là si on le regarde d'une manière
très pragmatique à la fois
coûte de de
l'argent est complètement je veux dire
complètement absurde dans sa dans sa
définition euh donc je pense qu'il faut
vite revenir sur cette sur sur cette
manière d'appréhender d'appréhender les
choses mais c'est sûr que comme on voit
comment les choses vont avancer avec ces
négociations entre les républicains qui
vont vouloir aller de plus en plus loin
je dirais dans fermer les frontières se
bloquer et se se recroqueeviller on
risque d'avoir voilà un texte qui va
être très très inquiétant tout de suite
on va rejoindre et bien unee des
nouvelles sénatrices de votre groupe on
l'a beaucoup vu aujourd'hui c'est c'est
Mathilde Olivier c'est la benjamine du
Sénat c'est aussi donc la benjamine de
votre groupe sénatrice écologiste elle
est votre micro Quentin bonjour
effectivement vous êtes la la benjamine
du Sénat un mot sur ce que vous avez
ressenti à être comme cela devant l'urne
à tenir l'urne pendant cette élection
c'était impressionnant comme rôle
aujourd'hui euh pas forcément
impressionnant en tout cas c'était
vraiment l'occasion aussi de rencontrer
tous mes collègues beaucoup de message
de félicitation aussi de ses de ses
collègues donc c'était aussi vraiment
l'impression le moment de rencontrer
tout le monde d'identifier aussi les
visages et puis bien sûr de participer à
ce moment important à ce temps important
pour le Sénat oui et puis on peut le
dire c'était la première séance c'est la
première fois que vous étiez tous réunis
depuis l'élection des nouveaux sénate et
la réélection des anciens le 24
septembre dernier qu'est-ce queon peut
dire du decorum aussi là il y avait les
348 sénateurs qui étaient présents
qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti quand
cette séance a été ouverte et ben c'est
quand même assez impressionnant de voir
de voir cette grande salle avec tout
tous les sénateurs tous les
sénatrices on en on a parlé un petit peu
de rajeunissement de féminisation du
Sénat on sait qu'il y a encore quelques
prod progrès à faire en la matière mais
bon on peut se féliciter que la moyenne
d'âge déjà soit passée au-delà là de la
barre des des 60 ans en dessous pardon
oui en dessous de la barre des 60 ans et
puis on a eu une petite amélioration il
me semble en terme de féminisation de
l'Assemblée alors continuons ouais
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé cette
fois-ci du discours de Gérard lcher à
l'occasion de sa 5e élection au poste de
président alors moi j'en ai retenu
quelques éléments il a parlé de
l'inquiétude des de la jeunesse face au
changement climatique alors je pense que
il faut pas seulement parler
d'inquiétude mais aussi de d'envie de la
jeunesse de vraim mobilisation et de
vrais avancées dans la en la matière et
on sait que le Sénat est une assemblée
assez conservatrice aussi sur ces
questions climatiques écologique donc
c'est important pour nous écologistes de
porter notre voix on sait que les
écologistes permettent permettent de de
de faire adopter un certain nombre
d'amendements ces derniers ces dernières
ont permis de faire adopter un certain
nombre d'amendements ces dernières
années donc continueer là-dessus il a eu
aussi quelques mots sur les Français et
les Français établis hors de France
c'est important pour nous notamment et
on parlait de de de de de l'Afrique on a
un certain nombre de compatriotes mais
aussi de de de de personnes habitants
localement qui ont par exemple fait
leurs études dans les ense dans le
l'enseignement français à l'étranger et
qui sont actuellement
bloqués bloqués pour avoir accès à leur
demande de visa voilà et peut-être un
dernier point c'est que c'est que il a
parlé de la crise migratoire avant de
parler de la crise climatique alors ça
pour moi je trouve ça un petit peu un
petit peu étonnant en tout cas je pense
que l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est c'est
l'urgence climatique et bien merci merci
pour cette réaction à notre micro et on
suivra vos premiers pas de sénatrice
vous serez très engagé notamment sur les
sujets de l'éducation et de la santé
donc on verra si vous portez ces sujets
pour le groupe écologiste dans les
prochains mois prochaines années merci
merci merci merci beaucoup Quentin oui
voilà Gerard Larcher il a eu un discours
il a pu s'adresser un petit peu à tout
le monde c'est peut-être aussi l'art de
ce type de discours Louis Vogel arrivver
à rassembler à pouvoir avoir un mot pour
tout le monde la longévité à la
présidence du Sénat c'est aussi savoir
s'adresser un mot pour les oppositions
un mot pour les majorités qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous qui qui arri moi moi
je trouve que le fait de vouloir dégager
des accords des compromis et cetera
c'est pas une mauvaise chose Heini je
suis je pense que l'essence de
démocratie c'est qu'on discute tous
ensemble par exemple tout à l'heure vous
parlez de la loi sur l'immigration édard
Philippe a dit que l'immigration pour
l'instant c'est l'immigration du fait
accompli donc il faut réguler alors
après comment on régule quelles sont les
mesures je pense que cette loi va dans
le bon sens son contenu il faut qu'on le
définisse ensemble mais c'est la bonne
direction elle plus S avec les les
passeurs c'est très bien être rappeler
les valeurs de la République c'est très
bien rappeler faire que quand on arrive
chez nous on apprenne le français c'est
très bien enfin il y a plein de choses
qui sont très bien et puis après on
trouvera il faudra qu'on dégage des
accords pour faire avancer les choses on
n'est pas là pour pour se contredire les
uns les autres et et se bloquer ça oui
c'est justement il a insisté sur le fait
que le Sénat la chambre tout à
l'heure on parlait de stabilité c'est la
chambre qui fait qui fait que il y a un
endroit où on peut discuter de façon
objective et prendre des décisions c'est
ça qui manque dans ce pays c'est qu'on
narrive plus à prendre de décisions pour
régler des problèmes qui qui sont posés
et nous sommes là pour ça Dominique est
S ne l'a pas employé ce mot de
contrepouvoir qu'il avait utilisé d dès
qu'il a été réélu comment est-ce que
vous vous définissez c'est aujourd'hui
le rôle du Sénat c'est voilà c'est
l'opposition constructive c'est le
contrepouvoir c'est un allié potentiel
pour le gouverement opposition d'intérêt
général c'est une opposition d'intérêt
général en tout cas pour la majorité
sindatoriale à laquelle j'appartiens
mais je crois aussi ce qu'il faut mettre
à à l'active de Gérard Larcher c'est que
depuis qu'il en exerce la présidence il
a relevé le défi de l'utilité du Sénat
on l'a vu dans les mandats précédents à
travers ne serait-ce que des commissions
d'enquête qui ont véritablement mis sous
les feux de l'actualité c'était
l'affaire benala c'est l'affaire des
cabinets de conseil c'est l'affaire du
fond Marianne et tout cela ben c'est
sain pour la démocratie et c'est
important lorsque on a à côté une
Assemblée nationale qui elle est plutôt
dans la politique politicienne alors que
le Sénat veut être utile à la France
utile à l'intérêt général et montrer que
le travail qui sort du Sénat est un
travail sérieux et bien merci merci
beaucoup à tous les trois d'avoir été
mes invités sur cette émission avec et
bien la principale information bien sûr
c'est la réélection de Gérard Larcher
réélu avec
218 voix cet après-midi pour un 5e
mendat donc à la tête du Sénat merci à
tous d'avoir participé à cette émission
on se retrouve très vite sur Public
Sénat n'hésitez pas à aller sur notre
site pour avoir toutes les informations
sur l'actualité politique et
parlementaire publsenat.f fa à 18h